OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO CALL TO
ORDER THE STATE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. SORRY. WE ARE TRYING
TO HOLD MANY COMMITTEES TODAY,
AND WE NEEDED TO. MR. BECKER AND
I NEEDED TO HELP APPROPRIATIONS
ESTABLISH THEIR QUORUM. SPEAKING
OF WHICH, LET'S ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM. ASHBY. HERE. ASHBY.
HERE. WHEN? ALVARADO. GILL.
ALVARADO. GILL HERE. ARCHULETA.
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER
HERE. BECKER. HERE. DODD EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. HERE GLAZER. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NILO. HERE. NILO
HERE. ROTH. ROTH. HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. GREAT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE. WE HAVE
ABOUT 20 BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. NO CONSENT ITEMS AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 2269 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FLORA HAS BEEN PULLED.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED OUR QUORUM
SO WE WILL GET STARTED WITH OUR
AGENDA ITEMS. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON, YOU ARE UP FIRST.
START WITH AB 2231. THE
PAWNBROKERS EDUCATION BILL AND
THEN MOVE TO YOUR SECOND BILL.
WOULD THAT BE OKAY? THAT'S FINE.
ALL RIGHT. GREAT WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY VOICE IS A LITTLE
RASPY FROM THE WEEKEND, SO
PLEASE EXCUSE MY VOICE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2231,
WHICH SEEKS TO PROPOSE A
MANDATED CONTINUOUS EDUCATION
FOR PAWNBROKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN
MAKING AND STRENGTHENING THIS
BILL. AND MAKING THIS BILL
BETTER. WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT BEFORE
RECEIVING LICENSURES, ALL
PAWNBROKERS WOULD RECEIVE AT
LEAST EIGHT HOURS OF TRAINING
FOR RELATED TO CUSTOMER SERVICE
BUSINESS PRACTICES, LAW AND
REGULATIONS, AND SECURITY, AND
ALSO ETHICS. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRES THAT EVERY TWO
YEARS, PAWNBROKERS WOULD GO
THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL CONTINUOUS
EDUCATION TO STAY UP TO DATE ON
THE NEW REGULATIONS, NEW LAWS,
AND NEW PROCEDURES. MEMBERS.
THESE THIS THESE PAWNSHOPS ARE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THESE SHOPS SERVES
AS AN IMPORTANT SAFETY NET TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL CREDIT
SYSTEM. OUR PAWNBROKERS ARE
STRUGGLING, WE WANT WE WANT TO
SEE THEM TO SUCCEED, BUT ALSO
OVER THE YEARS, WE'VE SEEN A
STEADY DECLINE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS, THE PAWNBROKER INDUSTRY
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAD ABOUT
1000 PAWNBROKERS. NOW IN
CALIFORNIA, IT'S CLOSE. IT'S
CLOSE TO 6 TO 700 FROM 1000 TO 6
TO 700. SO THE DECLINE IS
ABSOLUTELY REAL. THIS MEANS THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES OWNERS, HAS
BEEN FORGOTTEN. FAILED TO GET
SUPPORTED AND THE ATTENTION THAT
IS NEEDED TO THRIVE AND ALSO
GROW AT THE SAME TIME.
CALIFORNIA IS FACED WITH
MULTIPLE CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
IN RECENT MEMORIES, THE LATEST
PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT AT LEAST 9
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE UNBANKED AND NEARLY A
THIRD OF THE HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
CREDIT SCORES BELOW 650. AND SO,
IN SHORT, THAT THIS IS A MANDATE
CONTINUOUS EDUCATION FOR
PAWNBROKERS, THEY'RE IMPOSING ON
THEMSELVES. WE THINK THIS IS A
RIGHT AND A STEP AND A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH 22, 31,
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES IS A FAMILIAR FACE.
SENATOR, KATHLEEN GALGIANI, WHO
WAS A MEMBER OF THIS BODY, WHO'S
HERE TO SUPPORT AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S
PAWNBROKERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND THANK YOU TO OUR
AUTHOR, WHO HAS DONE A WONDERFUL
JOB IN BRINGING US THUS FAR WITH
THE BILL, THE CALIFORNIA
PAWNBROKERS IS THE SPONSOR.
PAWNSHOPS IN CALIFORNIA ARE AN
IMPORTANT FINANCIAL SAFETY NET
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL CREDIT,
LIKE SHORT TERM LOANS, CREDIT
CARDS, OR EVEN PAYDAY LOANS.
PAWNSHOPS DO NOT REQUIRE CREDIT
CHECKS OR GOOD CREDIT SCORES,
MAKING THEM ACCESSIBLE TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH POOR OR NO
CREDIT HISTORY. EVERYONE SEEKS A
PAWN LOAN. WHO SEEKS ONE IS
APPROVED BECAUSE LOANS ARE BASED
ON THE VALUE OF TANGIBLE ITEMS
PROVIDED AS COLLATERAL.
MANDATORY EDUCATION WILL ENSURE
THAT PAWNBROKERS ARE UP TO DATE
ON THE LATEST LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AT BOTH THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL. THE INDUSTRY
IS CONSTANTLY CHANGING, AND
PAWNBROKERS NEED TO BE AWARE OF
NEW LAWS AND REGULATIONS IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THEM. IN
ADDITION, PAWNBROKERS WHO ARE
PROPERLY EDUCATED AND TRAINED
ARE BETTER ABLE TO ASSESS THE
VALUE OF ITEMS THAT ARE PAWNED,
DETECT COUNTERFEIT ITEMS
COMMONLY USED AS COLLATERAL, AND
THEREFORE PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM MAKING A LOAN NOT SUPPORTED
BY THE COLLATERAL. EDUCATED
PAWNBROKERS ARE ALSO BETTER ABLE
TO PROVIDE ADVICE AND GUIDANCE
TO CONSUMERS, AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF FOR SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND FOR THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THE BILL BETTER, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
NO OTHER LEAD WITNESSES? NO.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ME
TO TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW. COME ON.
FORWARD ABSENT THAT, IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO IS
OPPOSED? THAT WOULD BE LEAD
OPPOSITION OR ME TO TESTIMONY?
ALL RIGHT, MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? RESPECTFULLY
ASKED. WHEN I VOTE. DO YOU HAVE
A QUESTION? QUESTION? SORRY I
FORGOT. GO AHEAD. OH, JUST I
KNOW I'M SO NEED TO TURN THIS
WAY MORE OFTEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. GIBSON, FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. I HAD A QUESTION
FOR YOUR, WITNESS, SENATOR,
RETIRED GALGIANI. ARE YOU THE
NEW BILL? DUPLISSEA YES. ALL
RIGHT, WELL, WELCOME TO BNP.
THANK YOU. MYSELF AND ALBERTO
TORRICO, WHO SERVED WITH ME IN
THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. MAY HE
REST IN PEACE. THANK YOU. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. YES AND WE SERVED
ALSO IN THE ASSEMBLY TOGETHER,
SO I HAVE SOME SORT OF DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS HERE, FIRST OF ALL,
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM? DO WE HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT BECAUSE THE
ORGANIZATION'S WEBSITE SAYS THAT
IT PROVIDES PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATION, AND I. BUT I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE WHAT THAT IS, BUT
IS THERE ARE THERE ISSUES
CURRENTLY DEFICIENT ISSUES IN
THE PROFESSION THAT CRY OUT FOR
A FORMAL EDUCATION PROGRAM, AND
IT CAN END UP WITH HIGHER FEES,
AND ALL OF AND ALSO POTENTIALLY
CERTIFICATION IN ORDER TO BECOME
A PAWNBROKER AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS TEND TO BE A BARRIER TO
ENTRANCE TO THE BUSINESS. AND
GIVEN ITS VALUE. AND I AGREE
WITH YOU, IT IS AN ALTERNATIVE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE NEED, COULD
BE MORE DIFFICULT FOR QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS TO BECOME
PAWNBROKERS AND THEREFORE HAVE
MORE COMPETITION IN THE INDUSTRY
WHERE AS THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL MAY GO IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THAT? THE PAWNBROKER
MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
ACTUALLY BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
IT IS A DIFFICULT BUSINESS TO
GET INTO AND IN MANY CASES YOU
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE THE
SONS OR DAUGHTERS OF CURRENT
OWNERS WHO THEN TAKE OVER THE
BUSINESS BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
DIFFICULT BUSINESS TO GET INTO.
LARGER COMPANIES, AS WE KNOW,
CAN AFFORD TO HAVE LEGAL COUNSEL
ON HAND. SMALL PAWNBROKER SHOPS
DO NOT, SO THEY THE OWNERS HAVE
TO TRY TO KEEP UP WITH THE
DIFFERENT STATE LAWS. THE
FEDERAL LAWS, ONE AREA IN
PARTICULAR IS THAT PAWNBROKERS
HAVE TO DO DAILY TRANSACTIONS,
DAILY TRANSACTIONS OF THE ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PAWNED TO THEM,
AND THE REPORTS HAVE TO BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO COMPLY
WITH. ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY
ALSO HAVE CHALLENGES ON A
BUSINESS LEVEL WITH JUST THE
EVER CHANGING INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THEY'RE TAKING IN COLLATERAL AND
LOANING MONEY ON THAT
COLLATERAL. THEY HAVE TO BE VERY
AWARE IF THE GOLD NECKLACE CHAIN
THAT THEY'RE TAKING IN IS REAL,
OR IF IT'S FAKE, THE DIAMONDS,
WHETHER THERE'S CUBIC ZIRCONIA
OR LAB GROWN, THERE ARE ALL OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT ENABLE THEM TO STAY
AHEAD OF THESE FRAUDULENT
PRACTICES FOR ITEMS THAT ARE
COMMONLY PAWNED, THEY NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION.
AND IF THEY CAN, IT HELPS THEM
TREMENDOUSLY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
THAT THE MONEY THAT THEY ARE
LOANING OUT ON THE COLLATERAL
WILL SUPPORT THE COLLATERAL. SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW THINGS AND
A FEW REASONS. COLLECTIVELY,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF YEARS OF
KNOWLEDGE ON BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW. AND ON BEST
BUSINESS PRACTICES. ALSO,
SECURITY IS A TREMENDOUS
CONCERN. NOW, YOU'VE SEEN THE
PROBLEMS WITH RETAIL THEFT AND
THE PAWNBROKERS HAVE REALLY BEEN
SUBJECT TO THAT AS WELL. SO ALL
OF THESE COMBINED WILL HELP THE
OWNER TO BE ABLE TO STAY ON TOP
OF THE BEST PRACTICES, LAWS,
REGULATIONS AND BE ABLE TO DO
THAT THROUGH THIS CONTINUING
EDUCATION CURRICULUM. AND I GET
ALL THOSE POINTS. I'M NOT SURE
THAT IT'S NECESSARY, THOUGH, TO
SET UP A STATE FUNCTION WITH
ADDITIONAL FEES. AS AN EXAMPLE,
IN MY PRIVATE SECTOR, ACTIVITIES
, I'M AN AUTOMOBILE DEALER, AND
THE STATE DEALER ASSOCIATION
PROVIDES THOSE SERVICES TO
DEALERS. AND THERE IT'S QUITE
COMPREHENSIVE IN TERMS OF NEW
LAWS THAT ARE AUTOMOBILE DEALERS
ARE SUBJECT TO A GOOD DEAL OF
REGULATION ALSO. AND, OUR
ASSOCIATION PROVIDES THAT,
KNOWLEDGE AND SERVICE. IT
ADDITIONALLY, WE HAVE A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION, BUT, IT, IT
PROVIDES TO US JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU MENTIONED.
AND AGAIN, I'M NOT OPPOSED TO
THE EDUCATION. IT'S VALUABLE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT. I'M JUST
WONDERING IF IT'S WORTH SETTING
UP A STATE ENTITY TO DO THAT
WITH ALL OF THE FEES THAT WILL
COME ALONG WITH THAT FOR
PAWNBROKERS AND EVEN THE
CERTIFICATION, ALL OF WHICH
BECOMES A BARRIER TO OTHER
PAWNBROKERS ENTERING THE
BUSINESS ON A QUALITY LEVEL AND
PROVIDING MORE COMPETITION AND
MORE COMPETITION IS ALWAYS A
BETTER THING. SO THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE. AND IF I IF
I MAY JUST JUST JUMP IN.
SENATOR, AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTION AND APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL PATH YOU'RE GOING
DOWN, I THINK, TO HAVE AN
INDUSTRY TO SAY, WE WANT TO TAKE
THIS RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE WE ARE A
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE STAY ON TOP
OF ALL THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT'S CHANGING EVERY YEAR. BY
THIS BODY THAT WE WANT TO MAKE.
WE WANT TO PROFESSIONALIZE
OURSELVES, AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
KIND OF KNOWLEDGE AS WELL AS THE
SERVICE THAT THE CLIENTS AS WELL
AS THE SMALL MOM AND POP,
PAWNBROKERS DESERVE TO HAVE. AND
SO I THINK YOU'RE SEEING THIS,
THIS BEING IMPOSED UPON
THEMSELVES AS THE INDUSTRY WHO
THEY WELCOME THIS. AND SO I'VE
MET WITH THEM AND THEY ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS MEANING MOM
AND POP, PAWNBROKERS
ASSOCIATIONS ALL BIDWELL,
CALIFORNIA AT THEIR CONVENTION.
SO THEY ARE THEY'RE BEHIND THIS.
IT'S NOT SOMEONE ELSE IMPOSING
IT. THEY'RE IMPOSING IT UPON
THEMSELVES, WHICH PROVIDES GREAT
LEADERSHIP, I THINK. OKAY, THAT
TO CLOSE, THAT'S A CLOSE. ALL
RIGHT. MOTION FROM SENATOR ROTH.
LET'S CALL THE ROLE MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA A ARCHULETA. AYE
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
THANK YOU. MENGIBAR AND JABBAR.
AYE. NEELO ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK OKAY.
THAT HAS SEVEN VOTES. AND WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT QUITE HERE
YET. THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON TO
YOUR NEXT ITEM. FILE ITEM TWO AB
2862. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WANT TO STIPULATE THAT MY LEAD
WITNESS WAS UNABLE TO MAKE IT AS
DUE TO AN EMERGENCY, SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2862,
WHICH CURRENTLY SEEKS TO
PRIORITIZE PROFESSIONAL
LICENSURE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
THAT ARE DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED
PEOPLE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2862 WILL
SERVE AS A FOUR YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM TO TEST THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PRIORITIZING
PROFESSIONAL LICENSURE FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
BY THE CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
FREEDOM AFFAIRS AGENCY. THIS
BILL IS PART OF A CUMULATIVE
ACCUMULATIONS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF RESEARCH AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE REPORT, THIS REPORT
PRESENTS EVIDENCE OF
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE FACING IN THE
PROFESSIONAL SECTOR. THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY A PRIORITY A
PRIORITY IS PRIORITIZED AND A
PRIORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. THE
CHAIRWOMAN WAS HERE, CHAIRWOMAN
LORI WILSON, BUT SHE HAD TO
LEAVE TO GO TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE, AT THE PRESENT TIME,
BUT THIS MEASURE WILL HELP WILL
HELP BRING PARITY TO OUR
COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND BY ALLOWING THESE
POPULATIONS TO HAVE
PRIORITIZATION IN LICENSURES, WE
BEGIN TO CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE EARNING OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE SEVERELY
UNDERSERVED IN HIGH SKILLED
PROFESSIONS, INCLUDING
TECHNOLOGY, BUSINESSES,
AGRICULTURE, AND ENGINEERING.
LAST WEEK, MY OFFICE MET WITH
THE COMMITTEE, CONSULTANTS, WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE JUDICIAL
COMMITTEE, WHICH IS ANOTHER
INDICATION THAT THIS IS A, THIS,
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
STRENGTHENING THIS BILL. I WANT
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
TODAY TO ENSURE THAT THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE, THAT MY TEAM
AND I WILL BE WORKING THROUGHOUT
THE SUMMER, TO GETTING THIS BILL
IN A BETTER PLACE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSULTANTS
WITHIN THESE COMMITTEES AS WELL.
I WANT TO SPECIFY THAT THIS BILL
HOPES TO EXPEDITE LICENSURE UPON
APPLICATIONS. WE WILL WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLARIFY
QUALIFYING QUALIFICATION
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THIS
EXPEDITION. EXPEDITION, WE HAVE
ALREADY SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS TO
THE LEDGE COUNCIL, AND THIS WILL
REFLECT IN THE UPCOMING DAYS. I
JUST WANT TO STIPULATE THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA'S HAVE,
EXTENSIVE NUMBERS OF
APPLICATIONS AND MAKING
EXPEDITING NECESSARY. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MANY OF THESE
BOARDS THAT ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
ASK QUESTIONS, OF THOSE WHO ARE
WHO HAVE APPLICATIONS AROUND
RACE, OUR INTENT IS TO HAVE A
HAVE THIS AGENCY, THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN FREEDOM AGENCY,
DETERMINED TO DESCENDANTS IN
THIS BILL, THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. THIS IS NOT A ONE TIME
FIX ALL KIND OF SITUATION. WE'RE
WORKING ON THIS BILL EVEN
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER, WORKING
WITH BOTH, COMMITTEES IN ORDER
TO STRENGTHEN THIS, AS I
INDICATED, WE'VE PUT SOME
AMENDMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS,
AMENDMENTS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS GIVEN, AS WELL AS THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, ACROSS THE
DESK, AND THEY WILL BE IN PRINT,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. BUT MY LEAD WITNESS IS NOT
HERE AS DUE TO AN EMERGENCY.
OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE HERE
WHO IS IN SUPPORT WHO WOULD LIKE
TO DO MAYBE BRIEF COMMENTS OR ME
TO TESTIMONY? I'LL SIMPLY DO A
ME TO MARGARET GLADSTEIN, WHO'S
HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD BE LEAD
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT NOT LEAD OPPOSITION BUT
WANTS TO DO ME TWO OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE I'M
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. AND BEFORE I ASK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS, I'D
JUST LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS, BECAUSE THIS WAS A BIT
OF AN UNUSUAL PROCESS. I'M GLAD
TO SEE YOU FEELING BETTER THIS
WEEK. AND NORMALLY WE DO PRESENT
FOR EACH OTHER, BUT LAST WEEK,
THERE WERE SEVERAL MEMBERS WHO
WANTED IT TO BE YOU IN
PARTICULAR, SO THEY COULD ASK
YOU QUESTIONS. SO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US THAT OPPORTUNITY. IT
DID JAM UP THE PROCESS A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE THIS BILL WAS DOUBLE
REFERRED, WHICH MEANS YOU ARE ON
OUR DOCKET TODAY AND ON THE
JUDICIARY DOCKET TOMORROW. SO
LAST WEEK, THE JUDICIARY TEAM
AND THE BNP TEAM DID TRY TO WORK
WITH YOUR TEAM ON COLLECTIVELY
ON THE BILL, WHICH IS SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL BECAUSE USUALLY YOU'RE
DEALING WITH ONE COMMITTEE AT A
TIME. IT WAS OUR RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE BILL DO A STUDY,
BECAUSE WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IS SO IMPORTANT AND SO
CONSEQUENTIAL, AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CLEARLY DEFINE
THE THINGS LIKE PRIORITIZE WHAT
THAT MEANS TO YOU. OBVIOUSLY,
THERE ARE NO LIMITS ON LICENSURE
. SO WHAT THAT PRIORITIZATION
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND HOW IT WOULD
LINE UP WITH OTHER PRIORITIES
THAT THIS BOARD HAS MADE, SUCH
AS GETTING PEOPLE IN CERTAIN
AREAS INTO PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES, ADDRESSING AREAS
WHERE THERE IS A SHORTAGE IN ONE
PARTICULAR, LICENSURE AND ALSO
WANTING TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES, WHICH
I KNOW WILL BE IN THE PURVIEW OF
JUDICIARY, AND ALSO TO TALK
ABOUT THIS AGENCY, NOT YET IN
EXISTENCE. AND ALSO THE
DEFINITIONS IN YOUR BILL DO NOT
QUITE LINE UP WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD'S BILL. AND I KNOW YOU
HAVE ALLUDED TO THAT, AND YOU
DID BRING FORWARD SOME POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS, BUT THEY WERE
BROUGHT TOO LATE TO THE STAFF TO
CROSS AT THAT TIME. SO I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE PROBABLY PUT THEM IN
YOURSELF. AND SHOULD THIS BILL
LEAVE THIS COMMITTEE TODAY, YOU
THEN WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THOSE.
BUT I WANTED TO LET MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW THAT WE DID NOT
JUST LET THE WEEK GO. WE WORKED
WITH JUDICIARY. WE TRIED VERY
HARD TO MAKE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND IT IS STILL
MY CONTENTION THAT THIS SHOULD
BE A STUDY BILL SO THAT WE CAN
DO GOOD JUSTICE TO WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. SO I'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES NOW, SENATOR MENGIBAR
, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HEARD IF I
HEARD CORRECTLY, THE GOAL AND I
THINK I UNDERSTAND THE GOAL IS
TO CLOSE THE GAPS, ENSURE THAT
THERE IS AN EQUITABLE
REPRESENTATION IN THESE
PROFESSIONAL AREAS. BUT IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY, PEOPLE WHO
ARE WHO ATTEMPT TO GET CERTIFIED
THROUGH DCA ALREADY WENT THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE STEP NECESSARY. AND
AT THAT POINT, WE CAN'T INCREASE
THE NUMBERS AT THAT CERTAIN
POINT, BECAUSE THESE ARE JUST
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY WENT THROUGH
THE COURSE. IF OUR GOAL IS TO
INCREASE THIS DEMOGRAPHIC IN
CERTAIN PROFESSIONAL LICENSURE,
MY QUESTION WOULD BE, WHY AREN'T
WE DOING IT WHERE THERE'S
ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE THE NUMBERS, SAY, IN
HOW MANY ARE, ACCEPTED INTO THE
SCHOOLS, HOW MANY ARE ABLE TO
GET LOAN REPAYMENTS SO THEY CAN
GO TO THESE SCHOOLS, GET THE
EDUCATION. BECAUSE AGAIN, AT
THIS POINT WE CAN'T CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
LICENSURE. SO I'M ASKING MY
FIRST QUESTION IS CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THIS IS GOING
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS DEMOGRAPHIC,
UNDER WITH THIS LINEAGE IN
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUNDS? WELL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION. HOPEFULLY I CAN DO IT
JUSTICE BY GIVING AN ADEQUATE
RESPONSE TO IT, WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS NEW
AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT, ONE, IT
WOULD IDENTIFY THOSE WHO ARE
LEGITIMATELY QUALIFIED UNDER THE
ENSLAVED ACT, RIGHT, WHO ARE
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES WHOSE
APPLICATIONS GOING THROUGH THESE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE. WHAT WE FOUND
IN THE 1100, REPORT OF THE
REPARATIONS REPORT THAT A NUMBER
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
DISENFRANCHIZED AND THAT'S THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE THIS REPORT
TO THIS POINT, THIS SITUATION
OUT. AND IT'S IN THE
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING PIECE.
AND THAT IF DISENFRANCHIZED FROM
BECOMING PROFESSIONALS OR
DISENFRANCHIZED AFTER THEY WENT
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE STEP THAT
DCA IS NOT CERTIFYING THEIR
HOURS, THEIR EDUCATION, AND NOT
ASSIGNING THEM A NUMBER, I
BELIEVE THAT IS THAT IS THE THAT
IS THE SITUATION, THE LADDER.
YES. THE LADDER, I BELIEVE THAT
IS. AND AGAIN, I WISH THAT MY
KEY WITNESS WAS HERE TO
ELABORATE ON THAT BECAUSE THAT
PERSON IS VERY IS VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE, ALL THE INNER
WORKINGS OF IT AND SO BUT I
BELIEVE IT'S THE LATTER. OKAY.
AND MAYBE THAT'S COMPLETE NEWS
FOR ME AND MAYBE MY OTHER FELLOW
PROFESSIONAL THAT GETS A LICENSE
UNDER DCA COULD HELP, BECAUSE MY
ASSUMPTION IS EVERYBODY WHO
CHECKS OFF THE EDUCATION WHO
DID, AT LEAST SPEAKING ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT, GETS
ALL THE HOURS NECESSARY, SIMPLY
GOES TO DCA AND SAYS, HEY, I GOT
EVERYTHING. I SUBMIT MY
APPLICATION AND ALL YOU NEED TO
DO IS CERTIFY ME. SO IF
EVERYBODY REGARDLESS, REGARDLESS
OF SKIN, SEXUAL ORIENTATION,
WHAT HAVE YOU SUBMIT, THEIR
APPLICATION WILL END UP GETTING
CERTIFIED BY THE DCA. SO IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT CORRECTLY,
MADAM CHAIR, YES. SO I GUESS I'M
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE. THIS I
MEAN, I'M, YOU KNOW, I'M ALWAYS
LOOKING I THINK ABOUT THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH BILINGUAL PHYSICIANS
IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED MORE
BILINGUAL PHYSICIANS. BUT IF I
THOUGHT CERTIFYING BILINGUAL
SPANISH SPEAKERS IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE DCA OR THROUGH THE
MEDICAL BOARD WOULD BE THE
SOLUTION, WE'D JUMP ON IT.
INSTEAD, WE HAVE LEGISLATION
LIKE BRINGING SOME FROM MEXICO.
THERE'S SOME YOUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUE IS BRINGING ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
VERSUS, VERSUS STREAMLINING THE
ACTUAL PROCESS. SO I'M STILL SO
THAT'S WHERE I STILL AM HAVING
TROUBLE SEEING HOW THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY EXPEDITE OR INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE. MY SECOND
THING IS I HAVE CONCERNS THAT
WERE THROUGH YOUR PROPOSED
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO HAVE THIS FALL UNDER
A DEPARTMENT THAT DOESN'T EXIST
YET, THAT WE HAVE DON'T KNOW HOW
IT'S GOING TO RUN. WE HAVE IN
THE DEPARTMENT, AND I HOPE
SENATOR BRADFORD'S BILL DOES
PASS, BUT I THINK THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP. LET THE DEPARTMENT
BECOME GO INTO EXISTENCE,
UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW, GET THE
STAFF UP AND READY TO GO AND
THEN COME BACK AND SEE WHAT CAN
THE DEPARTMENT DO, YOU KNOW,
WHAT DEFINITION ARE THEY GOING
TO BE UTILIZING? WHAT CALCULATOR
CALCULATOR THEY'RE GOING TO BE
UTILIZING TO FIND THE LINEAGE
AND SO FORTH. SO IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST A LOT OF OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS FOR ME. I'M GOING TO
STOP BECAUSE I THINK I'M
RAMBLING NOW AND LET YOU. SURE
SURE. NO YOU'RE NOT RAMBLING.
AND I APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS, UNDER SENATOR
BRADFORD, YES. THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THIS AGENCY THAT DOESN'T
EXIST RIGHT NOW WILL TAKE PLACE.
AND WITHIN THAT, THE 1100 REPORT
OF THE REPARATIONS REPORT THAT
HAS BEEN MADE PUBLIC, CLEARLY
INDICATES THAT THERE ARE, IN
FACT, SOME ISSUES WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
OF THOSE WHO ARE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN DESCENT. AND WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO IS TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO WANT TO GET
THESE PROFESSIONAL LICENSES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. AND
IT'S A PRIORITIZED
PRIORITIZATION OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ON ANY PARTICULAR
LIST THAT MAY EXIST. WHEN YOU
EVEN LOOK AT NURSING, WHAT WE
HAVE, NURSING NURSES, NURSING
LISTS THAT ARE 3 TO 2 YEARS
LONG, RIGHT. AND THERE'S NO
DENYING THAT. AND THERE COULD IN
FACT BE OTHER LISTS. SO I'M I'M
ASSUMING AND I WOULD BE SURE
THAT BECAUSE IT WAS BROUGHT OUT
AND THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE IN THE
REPARATION TASK FORCE, 1100
PAGES, IT HAS BROUGHT THIS
GLARING SITUATION OUT THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO. OKAY, WE
HAVE SENATOR EGGMAN AND THEN
ROTH AND THEN NILO, THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LIKE MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUE HERE, I'M. I'M
CONFUSED. ALSO. BECAUSE I THINK
WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO, BUT I JUST DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS THE CURE FOR THE
PROBLEM. I WOULD SAY FIRST YOU
HAVE TO SEE WHICH LICENSURES ARE
MOST UNDERREPRESENTED. RIGHT? TO
PRIORITIZE IN SOME KIND OF WAY.
RIGHT? IS IT, IS IT AN LCSW OR
IS IT AN ATTORNEY? IS IT A HAIR?
YOU KNOW WHAT? WHAT IS IT?
RIGHT. SO FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
AND THEN LIKE MY COLLEAGUE, I
MEAN, ONCE YOU HAVE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT THAT NEEDS HELP IS GETTING
PEOPLE INTO INTO EDUCATION. YOU
POINT OUT THE NURSING DEGREE,
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE A LOT OF
NURSING PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTED,
RIGHT? WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
NURSING PROGRAMS. WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. IT'S
NOT REALLY I MEAN, ONCE PEOPLE
GET EVERYTHING THEY NEED AND YOU
CAN GET LICENSE, YOU CAN SIT FOR
THE, YOU KNOW, YOU SIT FOR THE
TEST. SOMETIMES THAT'S ALSO
PEOPLE NEED SOME HELP ON THAT
AREA. BUT JUST SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO EXPEDITE ALL LICENSES
DOESN'T MAKE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME. AND I DON'T THINK
IT IT ACHIEVES WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE, WHICH I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN SUPPORT OF. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT I DON'T SEE
MYSELF. THIS IS, 1ST OF JULY,
WE'RE OUT OF HERE AT THE END OF
AUGUST, SO CONTINUING TO WORK. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. AT
THE END OF A TWO YEAR SESSION, I
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE VOTING
FOR A BILL THAT THAT WE HAVE NO
IDEA HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED, WHAT FORM IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED, WHERE,
OR ANY OF THOSE THINGS. SO IF
YOU CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT,
OTHERWISE I DON'T SEE MYSELF
BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. WHILE I SUPPORT THE IDEA
OF IT PRACTICALLY TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS, THAT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO ME. SURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR. AGAIN, ONCE,
ONCE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS
NEW AGENCY. RIGHT, AND, WELL,
LET ME GO BACK TO THE REPORT. AS
I INDICATED, THIS REPORT IS 1100
PAGES. AND THROUGH THE RESEARCH
THAT WAS DONE, IT HAS POINTED
OUT WHERE THERE ARE, IN FACT,
SOME ISSUES WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO PROFESSIONAL LICENSING. AND
THIS BILL, OF COURSE, TO SEEK TO
TRY TO EXPEDITE WAS THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS? I DIDN'T SEE THAT, THE
DOCUMENTATION OF THE OF THE
PROBLEM FROM THE 1100 PAGE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE
ANALYSIS. WAS IT DO WE KNOW
THERE WAS AN INTENTION TO
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BURDENS
AND VARIOUS THINGS. TASK FORCE
SUGGESTED IN ADDITION TO SOME
UPDATES TO AB 2138, THE
RECIDIVISM EFFORTS THAT MAY BE
SOME PRIORITIZATION IN
LICENSURE, BUT IT WAS JUST ONE
LINE. SENATOR EGGMAN, IT CAME
BACK TO SENATOR MENGER'S POINT
OF IS THE PROBLEM AT POINT OF
LICENSURE OR GETTING TO THE
POINT CORRECT? OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
SO THE DATA THAT YOU HAVE
SUBMITTED DOESN'T QUITE BACK UP,
DOESN'T, DOESN'T PROVIDE
EVIDENCE FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO, IS WHAT, AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
IT IS AROUND THE SAME TOPIC.
OKAY SENATOR ROTH. WELL, AS YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THEM, I SPENT A
LITTLE TIME CHAIRING THIS FOR
ABOUT THREE YEARS. AND
SPECIFICALLY, SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON NURSING, BECAUSE THAT
WAS SOMETHING I'VE BEEN AND
OTHER RELATED HEALTH ISSUES BEEN
FOCUSED ON FOR 12 YEARS. I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S, AND BASED ON
MY EXPERIENCE, I WILL SAY THERE
IS NOT AN ISSUE IN TERMS OF
GETTING PEOPLE THROUGH THE
LICENSURE HURDLE THAT, IS
SIGNIFICANT. WE WENT THROUGH
THIS WITH MILITARY SPOUSES AND
WHETHER WE NEEDED TO PRIORITIZE
MILITARY SPOUSES IN NURSING AND
THE NURSING BOARD IS PROCESSING
LICENSE APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
COMPLETE IN A FAIRLY EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT WAY. THERE MAY BE
MAY VERY WELL BE AN ISSUE WITH
THE NURSES THAT ARE APPLYING TO
BE LICENSED IN TERMS OF NOT
BEING REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO SERVICE, BUT THAT'S AN ISSUE
HAVING TO DO WITH, AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID, SCHOOLS
AND THE PROCESS BY WHICH
INDIVIDUALS ARE, ARE TRAINED UP
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY SEEK
ADMISSION TO NURSING SCHOOLS AND
THEN THE NURSING APPLICATION
PROCESS AND HOW THAT WORKS. AND
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THOSE THAT
ARE CALLING FOR A STUDY ARE
PROBABLY DOING SO WITH SOME WITH
SOME REASON, BECAUSE MAYBE WE DO
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
NURSING SCHOOLS AND HOW THEY'RE
SELECTING INDIVIDUALS FOR
ADMISSION INTO THE PROGRAMS, AND
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THE CLASSES
THAT GRADUATE REPRESENT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WANT THEM TO
REPRESENT. BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S IN THE LICENSURE PIECE.
I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE IF YOU SAY WE'RE GOING
TO PRIORITIZE THE LICENSURE,
THEN I SUPPOSE THAT MEANS THAT
IF YOU IF YOU HAVE TWO, TWO
APPLICANTS, ONE THAT MEETS THE
DEFINITION THAT YOU'VE YOU HAVE
IN YOUR BILL AND SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T, WITHIN A 30 DAY
LICENSURE PERIOD, LET'S SAY IT
TAKES 30 DAYS TO GET A
LICENSURE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ONE UP TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE,
AND THE OTHER ONE WILL FALL IN
THE LINE SOMEWHERE ELSE. SO
SOMEONE WILL GET LICENSED ON DAY
ONE, NOT DAY 30. AND IF THAT'S
YOUR INTENT IN THE BILL, THEN
FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL DOES. BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S YOUR INTENT. SO
I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT I
DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS GOING
TO GET YOU WHERE YOU WANT TO BE
BECAUSE WHERE YOU WANT TO BE IS
A LARGER ISSUE THAT HAS VERY
LITTLE, IF ANYTHING, TO DO WITH
THE WAY THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING, FOR EXAMPLE, PROCESSES
LICENSE APPLICATIONS. IF I'M
MAKING SENSE. WELL, SENATOR, I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WAS JUST
USING THAT AS AN EXAMPLE IN
TERMS OF NURSING, BECAUSE WE DO
ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S LONG
WAITING LISTS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THOSE WHO WANTS TO GO INTO
NURSING. I JUST USE THE LIST AS
AN EXAMPLE. IN MY ANALOGY, IN
THE ACTUAL REPORT OF THE 100
PAGE OF THE PREPARATION REPORT,
AGAIN IT POINTS OUT AND I CAN
ONLY SURMISE AND STIPULATE THAT
THROUGH ALL THESE HOURS OF
RESEARCH, IT HAS POINTED OUT
THIS IS AN ISSUE, AND THAT GIVES
RISE TO THIS PARTICULAR BILL
TRYING TO GET AT THE ISSUE. AND
WE REALIZING THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF THINGS THAT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE, FOR THIS THIS AGAIN, THIS
IS PART OF 14 BILLS OF THE
PREPARATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS REPORT
THAT'S MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE, REALIZING FOR ME,
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEES IN ORDER TO
STRENGTHENING AND TAKING THEIR
SUGGESTIONS AND TRYING TO
STRENGTHEN AND MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER, TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PURPOSE IS, IN FACT, IS MET IN
THIS PARTICULAR AREA. AND AGAIN,
THE THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
RESEARCH HAS POINTED OUT THAT
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO PRIORITIZATION OR
EXPEDITING LICENSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS OF, OF ENSLAVED
PEOPLE. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO, ACCOMPLISH HERE IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
ASSEMBLYMAN, WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUESTIONS FROM SENATORS.
OKAY SURE. SENATOR NILO AND THEN
SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL
BILLS THIS YEAR THAT WE HAVE AND
HAVE DONE THAT SEEKS TO GIVE
PRIORITY TO DIFFERENT GROUPS
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND THE
PROBLEM IS THE MORE OF THESE
THAT WE HAVE, THE MORE
PRIORITIES WE HAVE. AND THE MORE
YOU HAVE LOTS OF PRIORITIES THAN
REALLY NOTHING IS A PRIORITY,
UNFORTUNATELY. AND FOR THAT
REASON, I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. BUT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS OPPORTUNITY,
RIGHT? YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITIES. AND I
WANT TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING.
AND A FEW OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
TALKED ABOUT EDUCATION, AND I
WANT TO GO BACK TO A POINT THAT
I HAVE CONTINUED TO MAKE. AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE IT. AND
THAT IS THAT THE OPPORTUNITY OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUTH IS
HORRIBLY COMPROMISED BECAUSE OUR
K THROUGH 12 SYSTEM COMPLETELY
FAILS THEM. IT IS THE LOWEST
PERFORMING COHORT NEXT TO
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS IN OUR
K THROUGH 12 SYSTEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NOT BECAUSE OF
THEM, BUT BECAUSE OUR SCHOOLS DO
NOT SERVE THEIR NEEDS, DO NOT
PROVIDE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT THEY NEED TO THEN MOVE ON
AND BE SUCCESSFUL IN HIGHER
EDUCATION, ETC. UNTIL WE ADDRESS
THE FAILING, WHICH IS WELL
DOCUMENTED IN PARTICULAR OF
BLACK KIDS IN OUR K THROUGH 12
SYSTEM WERE HORRIBLY COMPROMISED
IN PROVIDING THE VERY
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU AND I BOTH
ARE VITALLY INTERESTED IN. I
WOULD SUGGEST YOU CHANGE THIS
BILL TO A STUDY BILL TO COME TO
FIND OUT EXACTLY WHY IT IS THAT
WE SO MISERABLY FAIL THE NEEDS
AND WANTS AND DESIRES AND DREAMS
OF BLACK KIDS IN OUR K THROUGH
12 SYSTEM. SENATOR NGUYEN THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I, I JUST HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS. I GUESS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS, IS
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM BROKEN IN THE
SENSE OF, DO WE HAVE A LIST OF
HOW MANY, DO WE HAVE A BREAKDOWN
OF THE DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE APPLYING
FOR THESE FIELDS, AND IF SO, ARE
THERE ARE CERTAIN GROUPS BEING
DENIED OR NOT, BECAUSE WHAT WHAT
I SEE IS THAT WHAT IF THERE'S A
FIELD THAT THERE ISN'T ANYBODY
FROM THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHO EVEN APPLY FOR IT.
SO DO WE FORCE THEM TO APPLY FOR
IT? SO THEN WE CAN HAVE EQUITY
IN THAT FIELD, IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST NOT AN INTEREST. LIKE IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN, IN ONE OF MY
PART OF MY DISTRICT, LITTLE
SAIGON, 60, 80% OF THOSE WHO
WORKS IN THE NAIL INDUSTRY ARE
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES. IT'S ONE OF
THE FIELDS THAT WAS SHOWN TO
THEM WHEN AFTER THE, YOU KNOW,
THE VIETNAM WAR, THEY ALL CAME
HERE AND NEEDED A JOB. AND YOU
KNOW, SOME FOLKS CAME TO THEM
SAY, HEY, HERE'S A JOB THAT YOU
CAN LEARN, CERTAIN NUMBER OF
HOURS. AND SO IT JUST BECAME
MORE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND IT
STILL CONTINUOUSLY DO. SO IT'S
LIKE 80% CALIFORNIA, 60%
NATIONWIDE. SO MY QUESTION MORE
IS LIKE, FIRST, DO WE KNOW EACH
OF THESE FIELDS? HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE APPLIED? HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
DENIED, AND APPLICATIONS TO
MOVE FORWARD? AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE, I THINK COMES DOWN TO
EDUCATION AND WHAT PEOPLE WANT
TO, TO PURSUE AND APPLY FOR,
BECAUSE I ALSO WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE ONCE
YOU HAVE YOUR EDUCATION, YOU
HAVE WHAT'S REQUIRED, YOU APPLY,
YOU WAIT FOR THEM TO VERIFY ALL
THAT INFORMATION AND THEN YOUR
APPLICATION GETS PROCESSED. I
DON'T THINK IT'S A PICK AND
CHOOSE WHO GETS THE APPLICATION
OR NOT, BECAUSE WE WANT MORE OF
EVERYTHING. WE DON'T WANT LESS
OF ANY OF THESE. PROFESSION, I
JUST THINK IS THAT WE MIGHT NOT
HAVE THOSE IN THE PIPELINE AND
THAT EDUCATION PART IS NEEDED,
FROM K TO 12. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
I THINK BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
WITH SOME OF THIS IS I THINK,
LETTING US UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
BREAKDOWN IN EACH OF THESE
FIELDS AND THESE EACH OF THESE
LICENSES, AND YOU KNOW, LIKE I
SAID, THE WHEN THEY APPLY, HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE? ARE THEY ALL
FULLY, YOU KNOW, QUALIFIED AND
IF SO, IF THEY WERE DENY Y, IS
IT BASED ON THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
INDIVIDUALS? WHAT IS IT? SO I
THINK THAT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
HELPFUL FOR US AS WE IF YOU WANT
TO CONTINUE TO PURSUE THIS,
BECAUSE I'M A LITTLE LOST. I
DIDN'T KNOW THERE WAS THAT MUCH
PROBLEM. I THOUGHT THAT MOST
PEOPLE WHO APPLIED GETS IT.
SURE. LET ME SAY I DON'T HAVE A
LIST FOR YOU, BUT MY TEAM IS
WATCHING. THEY'RE TAKING NOTES
RIGHT NOW, AND I'LL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION BEFORE THE CLOSE OF
BUSINESS TODAY. AGAIN, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS STILL
EVOLVING. THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS, AND SO WE KNOW THIS
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I MEAN, WE
TALK ABOUT. I KEEP HARPING ON
1100 PAGES AND MOLT AND
THOUSANDS OF HOURS THAT WOULD
WENT INTO THIS REPORT. AND IN
THIS REPORT, IT SHOWS DISPARITY
DISPARITIES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN, THOSE WHO ARE
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
CLOSE THE GAP. EVEN IN THE AREAS
OF PROFESSIONAL LICENSING, WE'RE
TRYING TO CLOSE THE GAP THAT
EXISTS AND THAT THIS REPORT HAS
BROUGHT AND HAS BROUGHT OUT. AND
SO THIS IS A SMALL PIECE TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
BUT YOU ASK A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER FOR IT,
BUT I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
GET YOU THE ANSWER BEFORE THE
CLOSE OF BUSINESS TODAY. BUT
AGAIN, THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS, AND I ASSURE THE
COMMITTEE AND EACH SENATOR HERE
THAT WE'RE PUTTING THE TIME IN
AND THE WORK IN NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THESE QUESTIONS MOVING
FORWARD. WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING, WE'RE ATTEMPTING
TO DO AS A CAUCUS AND AS AN
AGENCY THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
ESTABLISHED. THERE'S MONEY IN
THE BUDGET FOR IT, THERE IS A
STRONG, ENTITY IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO PUT AND LAY THE
FRAMEWORK IN TERMS OF THE
FUNCTIONS OF THIS PARTICULAR
AGENCY AND THESE BILLS THAT WE
ARE, ARE OFFERING WILL BE GOING
THROUGH IN SOME SHAPE, FORM OR
FASHION THROUGH THAT AGENCY THAT
AGENCY WILL PROVIDE THE
MANPOWER, THE SKILL SET,
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE ANSWERS
TO A LOT OF QUESTIONS. BUT MOST
OF ALL, IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL,
IT'S CLOSING THE GAP THAT EXISTS
THAT THIS REPORT HAS BROADENED
OUT. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
VERY WELCOME. OKAY. THAT'S IT
FOR QUESTIONS. I WOULD JUST I
THINK I'M JUST GOING TO FINISH
OUT BY SAYING I APPRECIATE THE
BILL, REALLY WANT TO BE HELPFUL
WITH THE BILL, GREAT. COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES. ONE MORE, IF I
COULD JUST ASK, YOU'VE SAID
REPEATEDLY YOU WANT TO YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEES. IT SOUNDS LIKE BOTH
THE COMMITTEES HAVE ASKED YOU TO
MAKE THIS A STUDY BILL, BUT YOU
DON'T FEEL LIKE I'VE ONLY HEARD
THIS ONE COMMITTEE, AND WE'RE
TAKING THAT UNDER ADVISEMENT
NOW. OKAY. BUT AT THIS POINT,
FOR THIS COMMITTEE, YOU'RE NOT
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A STUDY
BILL. WELL WELL, WELL, I'M NOT
YOU KNOW, AT THE POINT AT
LIBERTY TO, TO SAY YES OR NO TO
IT BECAUSE AGAIN, THIS IS PART
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS,
COALITION OF BILLS. AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO AT LEAST BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BACK TO THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND OFFER WHAT HAS BEEN
OFFERED TO ME BY WAY OF A STUDY
BILL. THANK YOU, BUT I WAS STILL
I'M SORRY. I WAS STILL LOVE FOR
YOUR. AYE. VOTE. IF WE CAN'T DO
THAT, I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COME BACK AND SHARE THAT WITH
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
AS WELL. SURE. GOOD. OKAY, SO I
DID SPEAK WITH THE CHAIR OF
JUDICIARY MYSELF AS DID OUR BNP
STAFF. IN FACT, AS YOU ALL KNOW,
BECAUSE YOU WERE HERE LAST WEEK,
WE HAD TO ACTUALLY COORDINATE
WITH JUDICIARY STAFF TO MAKE THE
EXCEPTION TO MOVE IT FORWARD.
AND SO I KNOW THAT IT IS THE
CONTENTION OF THE CHAIR OF
JUDICIARY AND THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ASK YOU TO DO A
STUDY BILL. BUT YOU HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO COME AND, AND DO IT
JUST AS YOU HAVE DONE TODAY.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IF THE BILL
GETS OUT OF HERE TODAY, I THINK
YOU'LL FACE SIMILAR COMMENTS
TOMORROW AND SOME DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THE CONSTITUTIONALITY. I
AM ON THAT COMMITTEE AS WELL.
AND IF FOR SOME REASON IT
DOESN'T GET OUT, I WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO WORK ON IT. STILL
COME BACK AND THEN MAYBE WE CAN
LOOK AT IT AGAIN IN AUGUST. IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT LATER.
BUT LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS HERE
TODAY. WE WOULD NEED A MOTION.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION,
WE CAN PUT IT ON CALL, COME BACK
AT THE END AND SEE IF ONE OF THE
MEMBERS WHO ISN'T HERE WANTS TO
MAKE A MOTION LATER. I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT, BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S SOME MEMBERS THAT ARE
NOT HERE. YEAH, THERE ARE SOME
MEMBERS NOT HERE. ABSOLUTELY.
WE'LL HOLD ON TO IT. THANK YOU.
MR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP WE HAVE MR.
FLORA, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FLORA.
ARE YOU READY? HELLO. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2578 ENABLES
CALIFORNIA NURSING STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN OUT OF STATE
DISTANCE LEARNING PROGRAMS TO
OBTAIN THE REQUIRED CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES AT CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE STAFF, WE PUT
TOGETHER VERY CLEAR LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT WE CANNOT DISPLACE
ANY CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
FURTHER, THE SCHOOL WILL PROVIDE
A LIST OF ALL PLACEMENTS FOR THE
UPCOMING SEMESTER TO PROVE THAT
THEY ARE NOT PLACING ONLINE.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN IMPACTED
AREAS. AB 2578 ALLOWS CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
ONLINE NURSING EDUCATION WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PARTICIPATING IN
THEIR HANDS ON TRAINING IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE
LIMITED THE BILL. WE HAVE
LIMITED THE BILL TO NON-HOSPITAL
PLACEMENTS, SO THE ONLY
PLACEMENT THESE STUDENTS CAN AND
WILL GET ARE IN REMOTE AREAS IN
CENTRAL VALLEY, IMPERIAL COUNTY
AND POSSIBLY THE NORTH COAST,
AND THEY WILL AND IF THEY CANNOT
FIND PLACEMENT, THEY WILL DO
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING NOW AND
MOVE TO ANOTHER STATE TO FIND
PLACEMENTS, TO LIVE AND FIND A
FACILITY THERE. MY BILL GIVES
STUDENTS A SHOT AT STAYING IN
CALIFORNIA TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION, BUT THEY CANNOT TAKE
A SPOT FROM A STUDENT FROM A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL. AND WITH ME,
I HAVE CHRIS CONTE WHO TESTIFY
IN ASKING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. SORRY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MR.
KHAN, GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES OR TWO OF YOU CAN HAVE
TWO MINUTES ON YOUR LEAD. CAN I
JUST SAY, CHRIS KHAN,
REPRESENTING NIGHTINGALE
EDUCATION GROUP WITH ME IS BLAKE
HALLIDAY WITH NIGHTINGALE
COLLEGE. WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT.
AND AS THE SPONSORS AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS. BUT WE WOULD LIKE OUR
TWO WITNESSES TO. SURE.
ABSOLUTELY. THAT SOUNDS GREAT.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR US
TODAY. MY NAME IS JULIE HEATH. I
AM A BSN STUDENT AT AN, A SCHOOL
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA, I CHOSE
DISTANCE LEARNING BECAUSE OF
SCHOOLS IN THE AREA ARE VERY
IMPACTED, I'M A MOTHER OF FIVE.
I HAVE A HUSBAND WHO. SORRY, WHO
. YOU'RE DOING GREAT. TAKE YOUR
TIME. OKAY WHO HAS MEDICAL
ISSUES? HE'S A CANCER SURVIVOR.
AND, I NEED NEEDED TO BE CLOSE
TO MY FAMILY TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEM. I'M SO SORRY. IT'S
OKAY. IT'S ALL RIGHT. YOU'RE
DOING GREAT. THANK YOU. I NEEDED
THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR MY FAMILY. AND TO
ALSO PURSUE MY EDUCATION AT THE
SAME TIME, THE SCHOOLS IN THIS
AREA I COULDN'T GET INTO BECAUSE
THERE'S TWO YEARS PLUS. AND TO
GET INTO AN OR, I GET INTO A
LOTTERY SYSTEM AND I DON'T HAVE
TIME TO WAIT. I'M NOT A SPRING
CHICKEN AND I WANT TO GET MY
EDUCATION NOW, SO THAT'S WHY I
CHOSE TO DO DISTANCE LEARNING.
THE DOWNSIDE OF THAT IS THAT I
HAVE TO TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA TO GET MY CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE, AND THAT COMES AT A
GREAT COST, AND IT'S, A HUGE,
HARDSHIP ON MY FAMILY AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS LIKE ME WHO
ALSO HAVE TO TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE, TO GET THE SAME
CLINICAL EXPERIENCES. WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU ALLOW US TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN HERE,
CLOSE TO HOME, TO BE ABLE TO BE
CLOSE TO FAMILY. I'M SO SORRY. I
KNOW THAT WE NEED NURSES IN OUR
STATE GREATLY, AND I AM ONE OF
THOSE THAT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP. AND, IT WOULD
ALLOW ME TO MAKE CONNECTIONS AND
HOPEFULLY FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WORK AND, LIKE I SAID, THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIKE ME
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH THE SAME
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT WANT THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES. RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE BEING RECRUITED OUT OF
STATE, AND SO WE WANT THIS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND BECOME
CALIFORNIA NURSES. AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU GIVE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. AND THANKS FOR COMING UP
TO SACRAMENTO. ALL RIGHT. I'M SO
SORRY. I LIVE IN CAMERON PARK. I
JUST WANTED TO. OKAY, GREAT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. COMING
DOWN, COMING DOWN. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
HEAR US TODAY. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
JONES. I'M THE OUTREACH
ENGAGEMENT MANAGER FOR
GENERATIONS HEALTHCARE. WE ARE A
SKILLED NURSING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SUBACUTE REHABILITATION,
ASSISTING LIVING AND SPECIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. WE HAVE 30 LOCATIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE WERE
ESTABLISHED IN 1998 AND HAVE
OVER 5200 EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY,
AS THE CLINICAL COORDINATOR FOR
THE COMPANY, I CAN ATTEST THAT
WE DO HAVE SPACE TO BE ABLE TO
HOUSE PEOPLE LIKE JULIE LIVING
HERE, OUT OF THE 36,000 PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA CHOOSING TO DO
THIS PROGRAM, WE ARE CURRENTLY
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
ARE AT HALF CAPACITY FOR
CLINICAL ROTATIONS, AND WE ARE
EAGER AND READY TO HOST NEW
CLINICAL AGREEMENTS WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP OUR
CALIFORNIA NURSING TALENT, I
WANT TO SAY THAT WE DO HAVE THE
AVAILABLE SPACE, AND WE CONTINUE
TO SEE THE INVOLVEMENT FOR OUR
FUTURE TO SHAPE HOW THESE
LEARNERS ARE BEING ABLE TO TOUCH
THE LIVES AND BEDSIDE MANNER AND
BEYOND. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU MAKE THIS CHANGE AND
SUPPORT THE AYE VOTE. THIS
MORNING. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
ALSO FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
AND SO ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
ROOM HERE IN SUPPORT ME TO
TESTIMONY. COME ON. FORWARD NOW.
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. SUPPORT. HOLD ON.
LET'S SAY IT AGAIN ONE MORE
TIME. WE JUST TURNED THE MIC ON
JORDAN. GO AHEAD. JORDAN
GERSHMAN, ON BEHALF OF DAVITA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI. CHRISTY
FOY, ON BEHALF OF FRESENIUS
MEDICAL CARE AND ALSO CALIFORNIA
KIDNEY CARE ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. REGINA
CARSON IN SUPPORT REPRESENTING
SELF. ALL RIGHT. THANKS DUANE
JONES OF CONCORD AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT. HI
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS XAVION
RODRIGUEZ. I'M A NURSING STUDENT
FROM ELK GROVE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE? ME TOO. TESTIMONY. OKAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RUN. WE'LL
WAIT. IT'S OKAY. THANK YOU.
ROSALIND GARNER, I'M COMING ALL
THE WAY FROM STOCKTON. I AM IN
THE NIGHTINGALE PROGRAM, AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FROM COMING
FROM STOCKTON. SENATOR EGGMAN
APPRECIATES YOU. YOU COULD HAVE
CARPOOLED. YOU COULD HAVE
CARPOOLED TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO. ME TOO.
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE
LEAD OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL,
BUDDY? WHO'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS? COME ON UP. PROBABLY
NEED TO ASK YOU TO IF YOU WOULD
GO AHEAD TO THE FRONT ROW. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. JUST MAKE ROOM
HERE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
HELLO WELCOME. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MARISSA CLARK, ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING, WE DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
FOR ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY RAISED THROUGH RECENT
AMENDMENTS, OUR FULL BOARD HAS
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE MOST
RECENT LANGUAGE, BUT I DID
DISCUSS IT WITH OUR BOARD CHAIR,
AND SOME OF THE STRUCTURAL
CONCERNS THAT OUR MEMBERS RAISED
ON THE PREVIOUS VERSION AROUND
LACK OF AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
MECHANISM AND THAT IMPACT ON
CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT DID STILL
REMAIN, UNFORTUNATELY, BY
EXEMPTING OUT OF STATE PROGRAMS
FROM THE APPROVAL PROCESS, IT
REMOVES OUR MAIN TOOL FOR
ENSURING THAT THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
STATE NURSING LAWS ARE COMPLIED
WITH, WE DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE BILL SHIFT TO NON-ACUTE
SETTINGS. HOWEVER, DUE TO THE
SCARCITY OF CLINICAL PLACEMENTS,
MOST CALIFORNIA APPROVED NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE ALSO UTILIZING
NON-ACUTE CARE SETTINGS EITHER.
IN ADDITION TO OR IN PLACE OF
ACUTE CARE SETTINGS, IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON FOR OUR PROGRAMS TO
REPORT LOSING THEIR CLINICAL
ROTATIONS FROM ONE YEAR TO THE
NEXT FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
REASONS. AND UNLESS THEY ARE
ABLE TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
PLACEMENTS, THEIR STUDENTS ARE
NOT ABLE TO PROGRESS AND
GRADUATE, WE DO ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE
ADDED, BUT IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT
CAN BE DONE BY THE BOARD IF THE
INFORMATION SHOWS THAT STUDENTS
ARE BEING PLACED IN AREAS IN
LARGE NUMBERS THAT ARE ALREADY
HIGHLY IMPACTED, AND WE WANTED
TO NOTE THAT THE BOARD HAS
PROVIDED PROGRAM APPROVAL TO OUT
OF STATE DISTANCE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS BEFORE, AND THAT DID
ALLOW THEIR STUDENTS TO DO THEIR
CLINICALS IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WOULD WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH MORE OUT OF STATE
PROGRAMS, RATHER THAN EXEMPTING
THEM FROM THE PROTECTION
PROCESSES THAT ARE IN STATE
PROGRAMS ARE HELD TO THANK YOU.
OKAY, GREAT. NEXT UP, YOU ALSO
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO RIGHT AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR ASHBY. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO,
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. I'M CARMEN CÁC, LEAD
REGULATORY POLICY SPECIALIST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING OVER
100,000 REGISTERED NURSES ACROSS
THE STATE. WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS, WE STILL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL,
OUR CONCERNS REMAIN THAT THE
BILL UNDERMINES THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA APPROVED NURSING
PROGRAMS TO PLACE THEIR STUDENTS
IN ALREADY LIMITED CLINICAL
SLOTS, THE RECENT AMENDMENT TO
PROVIDE CLINICAL EDUCATION AND
NON-ACUTE CARE SETTINGS DOES NOT
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM, AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS BASED ON BURN
DATA FROM 2022, 92 OUT OF 152
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA REPORTED
BEING DENIED ACCESS TO CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS FOR THEIR NURSING
STUDENTS. NURSING NURSING
SCHOOLS HAVE REPORTED THE
INABILITY TO SECURE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS IS ONE OF THE TOP TWO
REASONS FOR NOT ENROLLING MORE
STUDENTS. THIS BILL WOULD ONLY
FURTHER EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM
OF LIMITED CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
FOR NURSING STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE, ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
ALREADY STRUGGLING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND, AND STATE
UNIVERSITY PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY, WHILE THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS ATTEMPT TO
ESTABLISH TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ON WHAT THE OUT
OF STATE DISTANCE PROGRAMS ARE
TEACHING, THE PROBLEM REMAINS
THAT THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM WHEN THOSE PROGRAMS
FAIL TO COMPLY, THE BILL. ALSO,
WE DO NEED YOUR FINAL THOUGHT
HERE, AND JUST FINALLY, THE BILL
WOULD POTENTIALLY PLACE PATIENTS
IN DANGER BECAUSE OF
OUT-OF-STATE DISTANCE PROGRAMS.
COULD, COULD GET AWAY WITH NOT
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S CURRICULUM
STANDARDS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ME TO TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL SEEING.
OKAY, YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
MIC. AND IF YOU IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED, YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
MIC AND SAY YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS TAMMY VAN HALL. I AM THE
DEAN OF NURSING AT RIVERSIDE
CITY COLLEGE. I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION OF ASSOCIATE DEGREE
NURSING, AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
DOCTOR SHARON CRARY I AM FROM
EVERGREEN VALLEY COLLEGE, AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
DOCTOR ELIZABETH RILEY, I'M THE
DEAN OF HEALTH OCCUPATIONS FROM
CERRITOS COLLEGE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, AND I AM IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. RYAN BROWN,
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS,
SAN JOSE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SAN JOSE AND
OUR DISTRICT OPPOSES THE BILL.
OKAY. ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? THEN WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE DÍAS FOR COLLEAGUES.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS, COLLEAGUES?
SENATOR EGGMAN AND MENGIBAR. THE
BILL. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED.
WE HAVE THREE SETS OF QUESTIONS
HERE, BECKER. SO WE'LL START
WITH EGGMAN AND THEN MENGIBAR,
AND THEN BECKER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT'S INTERESTING TO ME
THAT THAT ARE THE PLACEMENTS
BEING HELD IN DIALYSIS CENTERS,
I GUESS, TO THE SPONSORS. IS
THAT WHY YOU HAVE A LOT OF
DIALYSIS SUPPORT? IS THIS A
DIALYSIS FOCUSED NURSING
PLACEMENT BILL? IT'S NOT, BUT
IT'S ONE OF MANY OPTIONS. AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
BE VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT
COMPETING WITH CALIFORNIA
IN-STATE STUDENTS, IN
PLACEMENTS. BUT THESE ARE THE
TYPE WE. ASSEMBLYMAN I'M SORRY.
NO PLEASE. I SHOULDN'T HAVE
JUMPED IN. BUT IF IT'S OKAY,
YOU'RE OKAY. MADAM CHAIR. OKAY.
THANK YOU. SO WE LIMITED THE
BILL DOWN TO NON-HOSPITAL
PLACEMENTS TO EVEN FINE TUNE
THAT WE AREN'T COMPETING WITH
THOSE SLOTS AT ALL, WE'RE
LOOKING, YOU KNOW, FOR THESE
STUDENTS, THEY'RE THEY'RE
DESPERATE. THEY ARE. THEY'RE
LOOKING AT WEEKEND HOURS.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT HOLIDAY
HOURS. THEY'RE LOOKING AT
DRIVING LONG DISTANCES BECAUSE
AT LEAST THEY DON'T HAVE TO
UPROOT FROM THEIR FAMILIES LIKE
OUR WITNESS TESTIFIED TO AND GO
TO ANOTHER STATE. SO DIALYSIS
CENTERS ARE ONE OF ONE OF THE
OPTIONS. BUT IT'S ALSO, YOU
KNOW, MANY, MANY OTHERS. AND THE
NON HOSPITAL SETTING. OKAY. AND
I, I, I HEAR WHAT THE OPPOSITION
IS SAYING JUST BECAUSE I'VE
SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR A
LONG TIME, AND WE KNOW THAT
PLACEMENTS ARE A HUGE PROBLEM
AND THEY'RE, THEY'RE LIKE GOLD
WHEN YOU GET ONE, WHICH SO I
UNDERSTAND, THAT YOUR, YOUR
STUDENTS WOULD LIKE ONE AS WELL.
IS THERE ANY NOTICE FROM THE
SCHOOL, I GUESS UPON, UPON
APPLICATION THAT IT DOES NOT
COME WITH A PLACEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. GOOD. OKAY BLAKE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. SORRY. I
APOLOGIZE THAT I'M NOT ENTIRELY
SURE. SO WHEN SOMEONE SIGNS UP
FOR NIGHTINGALE EDUCATION GROUP
TO GO TO A NURSING SCHOOL
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE, ARE THEY
ADVISED AT THAT TIME THAT THEIR
ABILITY TO GET A PLACEMENT MAY
BE COMPROMISED BECAUSE OF THE
ATTENDANCE AT AN OUT OF STATE
ONLINE SCHOOL? YES. YES
ABSOLUTELY. THEY ARE ADVISED
THAT, IN FACT, NOW THEY'RE BEING
TOLD THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THIS
OPTION. COMING TO NIGHTINGALE IS
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT. YOU DON'T
HAVE THIS OPTION. YOU HAVE TO GO
TO ANOTHER STATE. THE ADVISEMENT
NOW WILL BE YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY, NO GUARANTEES. YOU
STILL MAY HAVE TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
THEY'RE DOING NOW AND GO TO
ANOTHER STATE AND FIND A
FACILITY THERE TO DO THE
PLACEMENT. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, IF I CAN
ASK A QUESTION TO THE
OPPOSITION, I MEAN, YES TO THE
OPPOSITION. YES. GO RIGHT AHEAD.
SORRY. I'M TRYING TO HELP
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THEIR VOTES
TO GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T GET YOUR
NAME. I THINK YOU WERE THE FIRST
ONE WHO SPOKE. BUT YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING I WANT TO HEAR. IF I
UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY, THAT THERE
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
HELPING. YOU'RE WILLING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT? SURE. SORRY.
MARISSA CLARK, BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. SO TYPICALLY
, ANY SCHOOLS THAT CURRENTLY THE
LAW STATES IN ORDER TO HAVE YOUR
STUDENTS PROVIDE NURSING
SERVICES IN A HOSPITAL, YOU HAVE
TO BE UNDER A CALIFORNIA
APPROVED PROGRAM. SO YOU'VE KIND
OF GONE THROUGH OUR PROCESS,
CHECKED ALL THE ALL THE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES. AND THEN PART
OF THAT IS ALSO WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING TO MAKE PLACEMENTS,
YOU'RE COMING BEFORE THE BOARD
AND YOU'RE SAYING, I'VE WORKED
WITH OTHER SCHOOLS IN MY AREA,
I'M NOT GOING TO BE DISPLACING
OTHER STUDENTS. AND SO THERE IS
THE OPTION FOR OUT OF STATE
PROGRAMS TO ALSO GO THROUGH THAT
APPROVAL PROCESS AND HAVE THEIR
STUDENTS DO THEIR CLINICALS.
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT THEM FROM
THAT PROCESS, BUT THEN ADD SOME
PROVISIONS THAT ARE NOW LOCATED
IN THE BILL. SO CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW OUT OF STATE PROGRAMS, WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS CAN
APPEAL TO THE TO BERN AND SAY,
HEY, I HAVE THESE STUDENTS. WE
ARE REQUESTING FOR THEM TO BE
PLACED IN CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
CLINICALS. THEY WOULD THEY CAN
ASK TO GO THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS, WHICH IS WHAT ANY
NURSING PROGRAM IN OUR STATE
DOES, SO THEY CAN JUST APPLY.
WE'VE HAD, AGAIN, OUT OF STATE
DISTANCE EDUCATION PROGRAMS,
WHICH ARE THE KIND OF MAIN IN
THIS BILL APPLY TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. SAY WE HAVE
THESE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
PLACEMENTS, AND THEY GO THROUGH
OUR THREE STEP PROCESS, WHICH IS
NORMALLY STARTS WITH A
FEASIBILITY STUDY. SO BASICALLY
THEY JUST SHOW WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT ANYONE WE ENROLL, WE CAN
GRADUATE SAFELY, AND THEN IT
ALSO LOOKS AT WE ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS, WHICH MEANS THAT ANYONE WE
ENROLL WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA. AND ANY
TIME THEY MAKE SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO THAT PROGRAM, THEY
COME BEFORE THE BOARD AGAIN, AND
SO THEY ARE ELIGIBLE, THEY CAN
APPLY TO DO THAT AS WELL, MAKING
THEM A CALIFORNIA APPROVED
PROGRAM. AND THEN THEIR STUDENTS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO DO THEIR
CLINICALS. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU SHOOK YOUR HEAD. YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THE CURRENT
CASE, NO. I MEAN, RIGHT NOW
WE'RE WANTING THOSE STUDENTS
THAT ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT DO ONLINE CLASSES, YOU
KNOW, BASED OUTSIDE THE STATE.
WE WANT TO GIVE THEM THE ABILITY
TO GO TO DO THEIR CLINICAL TIME
WITHIN THE STATE. RIGHT NOW,
STATE LAW PROHIBITS THAT. AND I
WOULD LOVE IF THE SUPPORTERS CAN
ADDRESS THAT FURTHER. SO IT'S SO
THE PROCESS, THE BERN WAS IN
CHARGE OF THIS DESCRIBED DOESN'T
EXIST. THAT THAT PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY EXISTS FOR AN OUT OF
STATE SCHOOL TO BECOME A
BASICALLY LICENSED AS AN
IN-STATE SCHOOL. BUT THAT IS
LARGELY DONE FOR PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS FROM
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THE
PHYSICAL PRESENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE LEARNED WHEN
WE STARTED ON THIS ENDEAVOR TWO
YEARS AGO IS CALIFORNIA LAW
DIDN'T ENVISION ONLINE NURSING
EDUCATION. WE DON'T HAVE A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE. THERE'S NO
DOOR TO KNOCK ON. THERE'S NO
FACILITY TO INSPECT. AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE ABLE TO SERVE REMOTE
AREAS OF THE STATE FROM IMPERIAL
COUNTY TO THE FARTHEST REACHES
NORTH, SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS HAVE CALIFORNIA LAW
RECOGNIZE THE ONLINE OPTION THAT
CAN WORK IN TANDEM WITH THE
CURRENT PROCESS THAT WOULD
ALLOW, BUT STILL OFFER THE
PROTECTIONS OF OVERSIGHT FROM
THE BOARD. WE DO FEEL THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT IN THE BILL. AND
AGAIN, IT CAN WORK TOGETHER FOR
THOSE STUDENTS THAT CAN'T GET
INTO A NURSING SCHOOL THAT CAN'T
WAIT 3 TO 4 YEARS ON A WAITING
LIST THAT HAVE FAMILY
OBLIGATIONS, THAT FORCE OR JOBS
THAT THEY NEED TO WORK FULL TIME
AND DO THIS ONLINE. AND
CALIFORNIA LAW REALLY DIDN'T
ENVISION, NOR DOES IT ADDRESS
THE ONLINE EXPERIENCE. MY LAST
QUESTION, BECAUSE I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RURAL AREAS
WERE MORE REMOTE AREAS. I KNOW
THERE'S YOU KNOW, WE JUST HAD A
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION. IS THERE
A LONG WAITING LIST? IT'S HARD
TO GET INTO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE THERE EVERYONE
WANTS EVERYONE WANTS TO BE IN
THOSE COURSES, RIGHT? AND NOT
HAVE TO PAY SO MUCH MONEY FOR
THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS. I GET THAT.
I UNDERSTAND WE'RE LOOKING TO
ADDRESS, TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF HEALTHCARE EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA, HOW DO WE THEN CAN
YOU TALK MORE ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT PART? THESE SCHOOLS
AREN'T ACCREDITED, AREN'T
REGULATED BY CALIFORNIA, HOW DO
WE THEN HAVE CONSUMER
PROTECTION? I UNDERSTAND THAT
EVEN IF WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
THAT SCHOOL, THEY STILL HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR EDUCATION
IS, IN PAR WITH CALIFORNIA'S
REQUIREMENTS? I GET THAT PART.
BUT HOW DO WE THEN ENFORCE THIS
PIECE THAT WE'RE NOT STRIPPING
AWAY SLOTS FOR CURRENT IN-STATE
STUDENTS, AND IF THEY'RE
VIOLATING ANY PORTION OF THIS
BILL, THERE'S A WAY TO ENFORCE A
NONEXISTENT BRICK. AND MORTAR.
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. SO WE FEEL, AGAIN,
THAT THERE'S MANY MECHANISMS WE
ARE ACCREDITED IF WE VIOLATE
CALIFORNIA LAW, OUR
ACCREDITATION IS IN JEOPARDY.
THAT MEANS WE CAN'T OPERATE
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY. IF OUR
ACCREDITATION IS PULLED BECAUSE
WE'RE VIOLATING CALIFORNIA LAW,
WHO WOULD PULL IT IF WE DON'T
ACCREDIT YOU? THE ACCREDITATION
THE NATIONAL ACCREDITATION BODY
WOULD LOOK, WOULD, WOULD LOOK TO
SEE IF WE ARE IN VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA LAW AND THERE'S MANY
WAYS THAT THAT COULD BE BROUGHT
FORWARD TO THEM. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS THE ABILITY TO
ISSUE, CEASE AND DESIST IF WE'RE
IN VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND THEY CAN SUE THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
CERTIFIES US AS A PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
ENTITY IN CALIFORNIA. IF WE ARE
IN VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW,
WE WILL LOSE THAT. AND SO WE
CAN'T OPERATE ANY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND FURTHER, THE
BURN IS BEING PROVIDED
INFORMATION ON EVERY ASPECT OF
THIS BILL FROM PLACEMENTS THAT
WE MADE IN THE PAST, PLACEMENTS
WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE IN THE
FUTURE, TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE IN. AND LET ME JUST ADD TO
THAT THE BURN DOES LICENSE OUR
GRADUATES. OUR GRADUATES ARE
LICENSED AT A 90% APPROVAL RATE
BY THE BURN. THE BURN THINKS
ENOUGH OF OUR PROGRAM AND ENOUGH
OF OUR STUDENTS TO LICENSE THEM,
BUT THEY DON'T ALLOW OR
CALIFORNIA LAW DOESN'T ALLOW
THEM TO FINISH THEIR EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE BURN
GETTING ALL OF THIS INFORMATION
COULD ISSUE THEIR OWN CEASE AND
DESIST OR PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE ACCREDITATION
BODY, TO THE AG, TO THE BUREAU
OF PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. SO WE THINK THERE'S
MANY MECHANISMS TO ENSURE THAT
NO SCHOOL IS VIOLATING
CALIFORNIA LAW. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY. SENATOR
BECKER AND THEN ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU. I JUST WANT TO JUST MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT. I JUST APPRECIATE
THE, THE WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES. I DO APPRECIATE THE
SENATE-TV EFFORTS TO, FOCUS THE
BILL AND LIMIT IT TO
NON-HOSPITAL PLACEMENTS. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, FOCUS ON
AREAS LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
IMPERIAL VALLEY, POSSIBLY NORTH
COAST, I THINK THERE HAS BEEN,
AGAIN, A LOT OF WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE. AND, AND WE CERTAINLY
DO HAVE A SHORTAGE THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS. SO, I HEAR THE, THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION. I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS BILL, BUT I DO
PLAN TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR. APPRECIATE
IT. YEAH. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
WE'RE ALL AWARE THAT WE NEED
NURSES, WE NEED THESE
PROFESSIONALS. AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO OBVIOUSLY PARTICIPATE
IN FILLING THE GAPS. SO WHAT CAN
WE DO? WHAT CAN YOU DO TO OPEN
THOSE DOORS FOR THEM? IF THERE
IS SUCH AN OPPOSITION? WHAT WHAT
DO WE NEED TO DO IN CALIFORNIA
TO INCREASE OUR NUMBERS? ALL
OVER THE STATE? AND BECAUSE
WHETHER IT BE THE INNER CITY OR
OUT IN THE FARM AREAS, WHATEVER,
WE NEED MORE NURSES. WHAT CAN WE
DO TO OPEN THOSE DOORS? YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION, I
AGREE, WE ARE IN A PLACE WHERE
WE'RE NOT QUITE AT THAT,
EQUILIBRIUM. HOWEVER, GIVEN THAT
OUR IN-STATE NURSING PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN GROWING VERY, VERY,
RAPIDLY, TO THEIR CREDIT,
THEY'RE WORKING VERY HARD. WE
ARE ON SCHEDULE TO CLOSE THE
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA BY 2027,
WHICH IS WHEN A LOT OF OUR
CURRENT STUDENTS AND BSN WILL BE
GRADUATING. SO WE ARE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK FOR THAT. THAT BEING
SAID, WE AGAIN WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE THESE STUDENTS DO THEIR
CLINICALS. WE JUST ASKED, THEY
GO THROUGH THAT APPROVAL PROCESS
BECAUSE WHAT THE BOARD, THE
BOARD'S NOT LOOKING TO DO, LIKE
A CEASE AND DESIST OR LIKE A
LEGAL STOPPING, BUT THEY JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OTHER
SCHOOLS ARE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN THIS OCCURS
ON THE FRONT END. SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF CONSORTIUMS THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND THEY
HAVE THAT SHARED GOAL ALL THE
PROGRAMS DO OF WANTING TO
PRODUCE AS MANY SAFE, COMPETENT
NURSES AS POSSIBLE. THEY CARE
DEEPLY AS THIS SCHOOL DOES AS
WELL ABOUT THEIR STUDENTS AND SO
WITH THAT APPROVAL PROCESS, THEY
COME BEFORE THE BOARD BEFORE THE
PLACEMENTS TAKE PLACE. AND THEY
SAY, YOU KNOW, WE'VE WORKED WITH
THESE PROGRAMS ALREADY IN THE
AREA OR MAYBE WE HAVEN'T. AND SO
THAT GIVES THE BOARD THE ABILITY
TO SAY, EITHER YOU KNOW, WE
DON'T THINK THERE'S SPACE WE ASK
YOU TO REDUCE OR IN SOME
INSTANCES WE JUST ASK YOU TO
WORK WITH THE FOLKS THERE, AND
THEN YOU CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S EQUITABLE ACCESS. SO
WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO KIND OF PUT
THE HAMMER DOWN. WE JUST WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION ON THE
FRONT END RATHER THAN WAIT UNTIL
THE STUDENTS POTENTIALLY COULD
HAVE BEEN DISPLACED ON THE BACK
END, IF THAT HELPS. THANK YOU.
BUT WE ALL HAVE TO AGREE TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE. YOU MENTIONED
2027. WE NEED THEM NOW. AND IF
AND IF WE HAVE THAT ENTITY
THAT'S READY TO PARTICIPATE AND
OPEN THOSE DOORS, I DON'T SEE
HOW WE CAN STOP THEM AND SAY,
NO, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. OKAY, I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION FROM SENATOR ROTH THAT
HE ASKED ME TO ASK IN HIS PLACE
BECAUSE HE HAD TO STEP OUT AND
PRESENT ANOTHER BILL AND ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. I KNOW WE'RE ALL
RUNNING ALL OVER TODAY. SORRY.
THANKS FOR BEING PATIENT WITH
US. I THINK, CHRIS, THIS
QUESTION IS PROBABLY FOR YOU.
SENATOR ROTH IS CONCERNED THAT
THE $100 PAID ON THE BOARD FEE
IS NOT ENOUGH, AND WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU ALL WOULD CONSIDER
IF THIS BILL IS TO MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD.
INCREASING THAT AMOUNT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A SUFFICIENT
RESOURCE TO THE BOARD. YES
EITHER ONE OF YOU GO. WELL, YOU
HEARD FROM YOU HEARD, YES. AND I
AND I THINK WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THESE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WE PUT INTO THE BILL,
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO THE
BURN THAT THEY'LL HAVE TO TAKE
UNDER ADVISEMENT MAY ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL COSTS. SO, IT WAS OUR
ASSUMPTION THAT IF WE WERE TO
GET TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT THAT WOULD THAT
IS WHERE WE WOULD DEAL WITH IS
THAT FEE SUFFICIENT TO PAY FOR
THE BILL? I BELIEVE IT'S HIS
CONTENTION THAT THE BOARD SHOULD
SET A FEE FOR YOU. SO JUST BEAR
THAT IN MIND. THOSE ARE SENATOR
ROTH'S COMMENTS. SO SEEING NO
OTHER COMMENTS, I WILL JUST SAY
I APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THIS BILL
WAS ON FOR SEVERAL WEEKS AGO,
BUT HE REALIZED HE NEEDED TO DO
SOME MORE WORK ON IT, AND HE DID
SO. MET WITH A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION, TOOK A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS, AND I SEE SOME HAVE
BEEN WELL RECEIVED AND SOME ARE
STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS. BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU WORKED SO
HARD ON THIS BILL, AND WE JUST
NEED A MOTION. AND ARCHULETA HAS
HAD A MOTION FROM YOU. OH I'M
SORRY. THAT'S RIGHT. IT WAS LIKE
100 YEARS AGO. BUT SENATOR NILO
MADE A MOTION. SO WE ALREADY
HAVE THE MOTION. BUT CONSIDER
YOURSELF SECONDED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. ALL RIGHT. DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE? I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR
AND, MADAM CHAIR, THIS HAS BEEN
A COUPLE YEAR PROCESS, AND IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF WORK, BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
OPPOSITION. EVERYBODY BECAUSE IT
IS I MEAN, REPRESENTING A RURAL
COMMUNITY. NURSING PLACEMENTS
HAS BEEN SOMETHING WE'VE LOOKED
INTO FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW.
SO I'M JUST EXCITED AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO GIL ALVARADO GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER I
BECKER I DODD I DODD I EGGMAN
EGGMAN I GLASER MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NILO NILO I ROTH
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS WILK. ALL
RIGHT. IT HAS A NINE VOTES,
WHICH ACTUALLY GETS IT OUT, BUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL EITHER
WAY. FOR THE MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT
HERE RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY SO, YOU KNOW, WE
NORMALLY GO AND FILE ORDER, BUT
IF SOMEBODY WAITS FOR A REALLY,
REALLY LONG TIME, I MADE A
COMMITMENT THAT I WOULD TAKE
THEM FIRST. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VILA, DO YOU WANT TO MAKE IT
QUICK SO THAT SENATOR CARILLO
CAN JUMP IN RIGHT AFTER? OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2453, WHICH
CLARIFIES THE ROUTINE
MAINTENANCE TASKS THAT DOES NOT
IMPACT THE EV S¼ BEING CORRECT
DOES NOT REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
TESTING. THE CURRENT SYSTEM
UNNECESSARILY JUSTIFIES ROUTINE
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR TASKS OF
MORE EV CHARGERS IN THE STATE.
IMPORTANTLY, NONE OF THESE
CHARGES RESTRICTS A COUNTY
ABILITY TO ENFORCE DEVICE
ACCURACY REQUIREMENTS. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS SUZY
GOLDBERG WITH CHARGING POINT AND
MICHAEL BERG, MEGAN MEKELBURG
FOR THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGE
ASSOCIATION. ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. IF
YOU NEED THE FULL AMOUNT, LET US
KNOW. OKAY. GREAT. GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SUZY GOLDBERG HERE,
SENIOR POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
CHARGEPOINT. FIRST, WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER VILELA FOR
INTRODUCING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE. AS THE AUTHOR
EXPLAINED, AB 2453 IS A BILL
THAT WILL HELP STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS TO CONDUCT MAINTENANCE
ON EV CHARGING STATIONS.
CURRENTLY, ANY REPAIR OR
MAINTENANCE THAT IS CONDUCTED ON
AN EV CHARGING STATION REQUIRES
THAT THE STATION REMAIN OFFLINE,
UNTIL A REGISTERED SERVICE AGENT
CAN COME OUT, INSPECT THE
CHARGING STATION TEST TO ENSURE
THAT IT ITS METER IS ACCURATE
AND OPERATING CORRECTLY, AND
THEN PLACE THAT STATION BACK
INTO SERVICE. THIS TESTING
REQUIREMENT ALSO APPLIES TO
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE ACTIVITY
THAT DO NOT IMPACT THE
METROLOGICAL FUNCTION OR METER.
ACCURACY OF THE STATION. THIS
INCLUDES, BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO,
CHANGING A CONNECTOR CLIP,
REMOVING GRAFFITI OR STICKERS
FROM A SCREEN, OR, DOING
MAINTENANCE ON CORD MANAGEMENT
COMPONENTS. THIS ADDS
UNNECESSARY EXPENSES AND KEEPS
STATIONS OFFLINE LONGER THAN
NECESSARY, AND THIS IS DUE TO A
LACK OF REGISTERED SERVICE
AGENTS THAT HAVE TESTING
EQUIPMENT THAT CAN COST ANYWHERE
BETWEEN 45 TO $55,000, AND ALSO
THESE TESTS IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS ON THE STATION OWNERS
THEMSELVES, ABOUT 4 TO $500 PER
PORT, AND MANY CHARGING SITES
HAVE MULTIPLE PORTS. AB 2453
WILL EXEMPT MAINTENANCE THAT
DOES NOT IMPACT THE STATION'S
METROLOGY FROM THESE TESTS. THIS
MEASURE WILL HELP BRING STATIONS
BACK ONLINE QUICKER AFTER
MAINTENANCE IS COMPLETED, AND
WILL AVOID ADDITIONAL COSTS AND
HELP TO INCENTIVIZE OWNERS TO
KEEP STATIONS MAINTAINED.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
THE ROLLOUT OF EVS AND EV
CHARGING, AND IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE REMOVE BARRIERS THAT
WILL IMPEDE PEOPLE FROM
MAINTAINING THEIR CHARGING
STATIONS AND ENSURING THAT THEY
ARE IN GOOD ORDER. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2453. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GO
AHEAD. HI THERE, MEGAN
MICKELBERG. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
CHAIR. HI, MEGAN HERE. ON BEHALF
OF THE EV CHARGING ASSOCIATION,
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL. AND I'LL
MAKE IT QUICK AND JUST SAY WE
HAVE SOME REALLY BIG GOALS TO
MEETING OUR EV CHARGING GOALS.
AND IN ORDER TO SERVE THE CARS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ON THE
ROAD, IT EQUATES AT
APPROXIMATELY 359 CHARGERS
NECESSARY PER DAY TO BE
INSTALLED BETWEEN NOW AND 2030.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH HERE, WE REALLY DO THINK
THAT AB 2453 WILL HELP
STREAMLINE AND JUST REDUCE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO GETTING
THIS EV CHARGING OUT THERE. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. OKAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS
IN THE ROOM WHO ARE ME TO
TESTIMONY? MEANING IN SUPPORT
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF
OF TESLA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NICOLE HUTCHINSON, ON BEHALF OF
CALSTART IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. ARE THERE LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL OR
ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO JUST NOT
BE THE LEAD, BUT SAY THEY OPPOSE
THE BILL? ALL RIGHT, THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS FOR SOME QUESTIONS. ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE BILL? BILL IS
MOVED BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION. AND,
CLOSE. WE'RE READY TO GO. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I BECKER.
DODD DODD I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I
NILO I NILO I ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
I WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
TEN VOTES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL BECAUSE
WE HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE. BUT IT
IS OUT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YEAH, OR IT WILL BE ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR EVERYBODY
WHO CAME TO TESTIFY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO HERE NEXT IN OUR
FINAL ORDER. AND THEN I KNOW WE
HAVE ANOTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHO'S BEEN HERE A LONG TIME.
WE'LL TRY TO GET GET THROUGH
QUICK TO YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE, ASSEMBLYWOMAN.
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2327, A
BILL THAT WOULD ENABLE
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS TO
CONTINUE TO OFFER UP. I NEVER
KNOW HOW TO SAY THIS WORD. THIS
WORD OPTOMETRIC SERVICES FREE OF
CHARGE FOR UNDERPRIVILEGED
POPULATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY VISION
TO LEARN. AB 2327 EXTENDS A 2019
LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
OPERATION OF MOBILE OPTOMETRY
OFFICES BY NONPROFIT CHARITABLE
ENTITIES SUCH AS VISION TO
LEARN, AS LONG AS THESE ENTITIES
PROVIDED SERVICES TO PATIENTS,
REGARDLESS OF THE PATIENT'S
INABILITY TO PAY. THE LAW ALSO
DIRECTED THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
TO ISSUE REGULATIONS FOR
LICENSURE OF THESE MOBILE
OFFICES, BUT FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, INCLUDING A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC. THE BOARD WAS UNABLE
TO ISSUE REGULATIONS AT THE TIME
SPECIFIED. THE BILL EXTENDS THE
UNDERLYING AUTHORITY TO OPERATE
MOBILE OPTOMETRY OFFICES, AND
GIVES THE BOARD TIME TO FINALIZE
THOSE REGULATIONS. VISION TO
LEARN WHO SPONSORED THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION IS AN ORGANIZATION I
HAVE WORKED WITH FOR WELL OVER A
DECADE. THEIR MISSION IS SIMPLE
PROVIDE FREE VISION CARE TO
UNDERPRIVILEGED CHILDREN WHERE
THEY KNOW THEY CAN FIND THEM, A
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE IN TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS. SO FAR, VISION TO
LEARN HAS DELIVERED 227,000 FREE
PAIRS OF GLASSES TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS, PRIMARILY USING FUNDS
RAISED FROM PRIVATE DONORS. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS. I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO HARMONIZE THE
EXTENSION OF THIS LAW WITH THE
BROADER SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS.
HOWEVER, AS THIS MOVES TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND ON THE FLOOR,
I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS WAYS TO GIVE THE BOARD
MORE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT WE DO
NOT DISRUPT THE VITAL SERVICES
BEFORE THE SUNSET REVIEW, I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DAMIAN CARROLL, THE NATIONAL
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF OF STAFF TO
VISION TO LEARN. GREAT. WELCOME.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU. CHAIR ASHBY
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS DAMIAN CARROLL. I'M THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF VISION TO
LEARN SINCE OUR FOUNDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN 2012, WE'VE HELPED
OVER 1 MILLION CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ATTENDING. TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS IN 13 COUNTIES RECEIVE
VISION SERVICES. THE LAW THAT
THIS BILL EXTENDS, AB 896, WAS
PASSED DURING COVID AND IN THE
YEARS FOLLOWING VISION TO LEARN
HAS FOUND AN ALARMING INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN
NEED OF OUR SERVICES. PRIOR TO
COVID, ABOUT 28% OF STUDENTS
NEEDED GLASSES AFTER THEIR
VISION SCREENING. A POST
PANDEMIC THAT NUMBER HAS RISEN
TO OVER 33. AND RECENTLY, THE
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION CHILDREN
NOW REPORTED THAT IN 2021 AND
2022, LESS THAN 1 IN 5 SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN RECEIVED AN EYE
EXAM. THE GLASSES GAP IS EVEN
GREATER IN HIGH POVERTY. TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS AND VISION TO LEARN
IS READY TO SERVE THAT
POPULATION USING OUR CALIFORNIA
LICENSED OPTOMETRISTS AND THE
FUNDING WE RAISED FROM GENEROUS
DONORS. AND ONLY ABOUT 5% OF OUR
FUNDING COMES FROM MEDI-CAL. WE
WERE HOPING TO RAISE THE
EXISTING CAP ON THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES IN THIS BILL, BUT WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE INFORMED THAT
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE CAP WILL BE
PART OF THE SUNSET REVIEW.
HOWEVER, THE NEAR TERM IMPACT OF
THE 12 CLINIC CAP MAY MEAN FEWER
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE OUR
SERVICES. OUR ORGANIZATION
CURRENTLY HAS FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO OPERATE 16 MOBILE CLINICS IN
THE COMING SCHOOL YEAR. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY
AREA SACRAMENTO REGION. THE
CURRENT HARD CAP OF 12 MOBILE
OFFICES WILL LIMIT OUR ABILITY
TO SERVE AS MANY KIDS IN NEED AS
WE HAVE FUNDING FOR. WE ARE
HOPING TO CONTINUE OUR WORK WITH
THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY AND THIS
COMMITTEE OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS TO FIND A WAY FOR US TO
OPERATE TO OUR CAPACITY IF WE
CAN SHOW IRREPARABLE HARM, TO AT
RISK POPULATIONS. WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND FOR
THEIR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
UNIQUE MISSION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GREG PRUDEN,
EXECUTIVE OFFICER, CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY,
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND JUST
WANTED TO ECHO THE COMMENTS BY
THE SPONSOR OF VISION TO LEARN.
WE'VE ENJOYED PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ORGANIZATION. LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING FURTHER IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE ENTER SUNSET
REVIEW AND CONTINUE TALKING
ABOUT ITEMS LIKE THE CAP AND
OTHER ISSUES AROUND THE MOBILE
OPTOMETRIC OFFICE PROGRAM.
AGAIN, THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT BILL.
THANK YOU. NICE TO SEE YOU, MR.
PRUDEN. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE ANY
ANYBODY ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ME TO
HEAR? NO OKAY. AS THEIR LEAD
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO JUST
STATE THEIR OPPOSITION ON THE
RECORD, SEEING NONE? WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE DÍAS. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL, I'LL MAKE
THIS QUICK. I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, I A QUICK
TRIVIA QUESTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE. WHAT'S THE EARLIEST
THAT A CHILD CAN GET A OPTOMETRY
EXAM? ANYBODY? ANYBODY ANYBODY?
I DON'T KNOW, IT'S ACTUALLY SIX
WEEKS IS WHAT I LEARNED. I WAS
FLABBERGASTED, I RAISED THREE
KIDS, ALL OF THEM WITH WITH,
ASSISTED EYEWEAR AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL MY DAUGHTER, SHE'S GOING
TO KILL ME, FELL OFF THE MONKEY
BARS BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T SEE
HIM. SHE WAS JUMPING AND, LIKE,
BROKE HER NOSE. SO THAT'S HOW I
LEARNED SHE NEEDED GLASSES. SO
TO ALL THE PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS OUT THERE, I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A PLUG SIX WEEKS
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL WHEN, WHEN READY. WE
ALL LEARNED SO MUCH IN THIS
COMMITTEE. GREAT. OKAY, SENATOR
NILO. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
JUST CAN'T RESIST, MAKING THE
COMMENT, THAT I SEE HERE ONE OF
THE CLEVEREST ACRONYMS I'VE EVER
SEEN. MOBILE OPTIMIZED
OPTOMETRIC OFFICES. MOVE TO.
THAT'S GREAT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT,
WE HAVE A OKAY. YES, I'VE LOST
THEM ALL. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR.
OH, BOY. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU. I GUESS I JUST WANTED TO
ASK IF PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
LICENSED FOR SO MANY CLINICS. IF
THEY NEED MORE, ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ALLOW MORE MOBILE
CLINICS IN, OR DOES THIS, DOES
IT PREVENT IT WITH THE NUMBER
THAT WE HAVE ON NOW, WE WILL DO
THAT IN THE SUNSET REVIEW.
THEY'VE AGREED GRACIOUSLY TO LET
THE SUNSET REVIEW DETERMINE THAT
NEXT YEAR. RIGHT NOW THERE IS A
CAP. DID YOU WANT TO DAMON? YES.
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY ABOUT
DOING EXACTLY THAT, ADDRESSING
THIS DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW.
AND WE'RE REVIEWING OUR OPTIONS
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE AS MANY KIDS
IN NEED AS POSSIBLE DURING THIS,
YOU KNOW, DIFFICULT TIME IN THE
INTERIM. BUT OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE BOARD HAVE BEEN VERY
FRUITFUL AND WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. I WOULD JUST ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH THE SENATOR
FROM THE WHOLE EASTERN SIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. JUST TO SAY, IF IT
WORKS, WE WANT IT TO KEEP
WORKING. WE DON'T WANT TO LIMIT
THE AMOUNT OF KIDS THAT ARE ABLE
TO SEE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL
REPRESENTING ALL OF CALIFORNIA,
AND WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. MAY I
MAY I CLOSE? YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
GO AHEAD. SURE. THANK YOU, I
JUST I WANT TO JUST AGAIN THANK
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK ULTIMATELY,
WE SPENT SO MUCH MONEY ON
EDUCATION, BUT IF I SHOULD SAY,
WE INVEST SO MUCH MONEY IN
EDUCATION. BUT ULTIMATELY, IF A
CHILD CAN'T READ A BOOK AND THEY
CAN'T SEE THE BOARD, THEN WHAT
ARE WE DOING? AND I JUST WANT TO
SHARE SOME SOME QUICK NUMBERS IF
I CAN. SENATOR ARCHULETA IN YOUR
DISTRICT, SINCE INCEPTION,
20,000 KIDS HAVE BEEN SERVED.
5400 HAVE BEEN GIVEN FREE
GLASSES. SENATOR MENGIBAR,
40,000 STUDENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT
9653 HAVE BEEN GIVEN FREE
GLASSES. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS 150,000 KIDS SERVED,
36,865 HAVE BEEN GIVEN GLASSES.
SENATOR ROTH, SINCE INCEPTION IN
THE NEWEST COUNTY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. SENATOR ROTH NOT HERE
YET, HIS REGION, 20,000 KIDS
SERVED 6500. I'M SORRY, 5135
HAVE BEEN GIVEN FREE GLASSES.
THE MORE MOBILE CLINICS WE HAVE,
THE MORE ACCESS WE HAVE TO
STUDENTS, THE MORE THE MORE
STUDENTS WE ARE ABLE TO SERVE.
AND THE MORE STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO LEARN AND GRADUATE AND BE
PRODUCTIVE CALIFORNIANS. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT,
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER. DODD AYE. DODD.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE NIELLO.
AYE. NIELLO. AYE. ROTH.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK AYE.
WILK. AYE OKAY. YOU HAVE NINE
VOTES, WHICH IS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT, BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
AND ON THE ROLL FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO AREN'T QUITE HERE
YET. OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, AND THANK YOU TO
YOUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN BECAUSE HE
GETS OUR PATIENTS AWARD FOR THE
DAY FOR BEING HERE FOR A LONG
TIME. THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THE
PRIVILEGE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES, LIMÓN CARILLO,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AHEAD
OF HIM. AGAIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
3167. I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND MADAM CHAIR, YOUR
INCREDIBLE STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE FOR IMPROVING THE
BILL AND MAKING IT BETTER
THROUGH ANALYSIS. AND WE'LL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
MANY NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES FALL
INTO THE SAME REGULATORY
CATEGORY AS VOCATIONAL SCHOOLS.
THIS IMPORTANT LAW, ESTABLISHED
TO PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
PREDATORY INSTITUTIONS, NOW HAS
AN OUTSIZED EFFECT ON
INSTITUTIONS THAT MERGE WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS SUCH AS
NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY AND
MILLS COLLEGE. WHILE THIS
IMPORTANT LAW PROTECTS AGAINST
FRAUD THAT COULD LEAD TO LOSS OF
STUDENTS TUITION AND FEES AND NO
LONGER SERVES STUDENTS ATTENDING
CERTAINLY HIGHLY QUALIFIED
INSTITUTIONS THAT REMAIN
COMMITTED TO EDUCATING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AS MORE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MERGE, STUDENTS
ATTENDING THOSE INSTITUTIONS ARE
UNFAIRLY BURDENED WITH FEES AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT OTHER STUDENTS
DO NOT HAVE TO PAY. CURRENTLY,
STUDENTS ATTENDING NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES REGULATED BY
PRIVATE POST-SECONDARY BUREAU
MUST DECLARE A COURSE OF STUDY A
MAJOR BEFORE BEGINNING COURSES.
STUDENTS MUST ALSO PAY A FEE TO
STUDENT TUITION RECOVERY FUND.
STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES ARE EXEMPT FROM
BUREAU REGULATION, ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DECLARE A MAJOR, OR
PAY THE STUDENT TUITION RECOVERY
FUND. AS MORE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MERGE, HIGHLY
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS
WITH APPROVAL TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO SUBJECT STUDENTS TO
A BURDENSOME RESTRICTION BASED
ON BUREAU RULES THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED FOR MORE RISKY
INSTITUTIONS. AB 3167 OFFERS
HIGHLY QUALIFIED INSTITUTIONS
AND ALTERNATIVES TO APPROVAL
PATHWAY WHILE MAINTAINING BUREAU
OVERSIGHT AND SAFEGUARD FOR
STUDENTS. I'M HERE TO TESTIFY.
WE HAVE RENAME JEALOUS LOVER OF
NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY AND ALEX
GRAVES OF IQ. WE ALSO HAVE MIKE
FERRARI OF NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU. EACH OF YOUR
WITNESSES HAS TWO MINUTES HAS
BEEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS RENE LEVER. I'M VICE
PRESIDENT FOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATION AND STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES AT NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY, OAKLAND. PRIOR TO
JOINING NORTHEASTERN FOR 31
YEARS, I SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
LEADERSHIP ROLES AT MILLS
COLLEGE, A PRIVATE, HISTORIC
LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGE AND LEADER
ON ISSUES OF EQUITY, SOCIAL
JUSTICE, AND WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP.
FOUNDED IN 1898, NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY IS A COMPREHENSIVE,
NONPROFIT, GLOBAL RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY AND A RECOGNIZED
LEADER IN EXPERIENTIAL LEARNING.
IN JULY OF 2022, MILLS MERGED
WITH NORTHEASTERN, JOINING
NORTHEASTERN'S NETWORK OF 13
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES, CANADA, AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM, INCLUDING A CAMPUS
OFFERING GRADUATE DEGREE
PROGRAMS IN SAN JOSE, WHICH
OPENED IN 2015. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, HIGH QUALITY NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAY MAINTAIN A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA,
BUT WHICH ARE HEADQUARTERED
OUTSIDE THE STATE, SUCH AS
NORTHEASTERN, FALL INTO THE SAME
REGULATORY CATEGORY AS PRIVATE
NONPROFIT I'M SORRY, PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS AND
VOCATIONAL SCHOOLS OFFERING
SHORT TERM TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THE INTENT OF AB 3167 IS SIMPLE
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
OVERSIGHT FROM THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
FOR HIGH QUALITY NONPROFITS LIKE
NORTHEASTERN, BUT ONLY WHEN
THOSE INSTITUTIONS MEET RIGOROUS
QUALITY STANDARDS, PROTECT
STUDENTS, AND MAINTAIN CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS. IMPORTANTLY, THE
BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT IMPEDE STUDENT ACADEMIC
PROGRESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. FOR EXAMPLE, AT
COMPREHENSIVE NONPROFIT RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES, ACADEMIC
EXPLORATION AND DISCOVERY ARE
THE HALLMARK OF AN UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION, PARTICULARLY DURING
THE FIRST YEAR. THIS BILL WOULD
CORRECT THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING STUDENTS AT SUCH
INSTITUTIONS TO ENROLL IN DEGREE
PROGRAMS BEFORE THEY HAVE AGREED
ON A MAJOR OR CAREER PATHWAY.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WOULD
EASE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
REDUCE DELAYS FOR NEW PROGRAM
APPROVALS SO THAT HIGHLY
QUALIFIED NONPROFITS CAN RESPOND
QUICKLY TO MARKET DEMANDS AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS FOR SKILLED TALENT.
FINALLY, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE'S CHIEF CONSULTANT,
SARAH MASON, FOR HER REVIEW OF
THE BILL AND FOR HER EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN AND CLARIFY CERTAIN
PROVISIONS. WE ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT STEP. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. OKAY. NOW IT'S ON. OKAY,
GREAT. GOOD MORNING. I THINK
STILL, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ALEX
GRAVES, THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES, REPRESENTING
89 PRIVATE, NONPROFIT,
ACCREDITED COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WHILE OUR MEMBERS ARE
EXEMPT FROM BP, WE DO APPRECIATE
AND VALUE THE ROLE THEY PLAY IN
PROVIDING CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND SAFEGUARDS FOR STUDENTS WITH
A CHANGING HIGHER EDUCATION
LANDSCAPE. WE THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATION PROPOSES SOME MODEST
BUT IMPORTANT CHANGES, THAT
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN OUTLINED AS THEY RELATE TO
NORTHEASTERN, WHILE ALSO
CONTINUING TO ENSURE WE DO HAVE
STRONG CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE THROUGH THE BP'S
FUNCTIONS. SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
JUST THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF? I KNOW
YOU'RE JUST FOR SURE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MIKE
FERRARI, ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
AT NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
AS ME TO TESTIMONY? NOPE. OKAY.
AS THEIR LEAD OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL. COME ON. FORWARD. WE HAVE
ONE MORE CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SABRINA MEANS, ON
BEHALF OF THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS,
BETTER KNOWN AS TEXAS. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE CERTAIN ASPECTS OF AB
367, WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL UNLESS IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED TO ENSURE
THERE ARE EFFECTIVE PROTECTIONS
FOR STUDENTS AND THE FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION,
AS WRITTEN, THIS BILL CAN
POTENTIALLY OPEN THE DOOR FOR
OTHER OUT OF STATE, NONPROFIT,
OR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT SIMILAR MECHANISMS FOR
ACCESSING FEDERAL AND STATE
FINANCIAL AID, WHICH IS ALREADY
VERY LIMITED IN AVAILABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ATTENDING
THE STATE'S PUBLIC PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. THE REGISTRATION
FEE AMOUNT FOR THE BP SET BY AB
3167 IS INSUFFICIENT TO COVER
THE COSTS OF AGENCY STAFF,
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. WE RECOMMEND AN
ANNUAL FEE INSTEAD OF ONCE PER
DECADE FEE. WE ARE FURTHER
RECOMMENDING A TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATION THAT
NON-ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS MUST
REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU, SO
THERE IS AT LEAST A MARGINAL
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT AS OPPOSED TO
NONE. MOREOVER, TO PREVENT THE
RISE OF SHELL NONPROFITS, A
PROVISION SHOULD BE ADDED TO
LIMIT THE PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
PAID BY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO
THIRD PARTIES. WE RECOMMEND THAT
NO MORE THAN 25% OF TUITION BE
PAID TO A THIRD PARTY, ENSURING
FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. FINALLY, THERE
NEEDS TO BE AT LEAST SOME LEVEL
OF REPORTING METRICS FROM THE
BUREAU TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THE OVERSIGHT OF STUDENT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IS
OPERATING WELL ENOUGH. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AS WELL? ALL RIGHT
. SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE DÍAS COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS? SEEING
NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE A CHANCE TO
CLOSE? MADAM CHAIR, I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
ALSO, I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. I'LL BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION. OUR GOAL IS TO
REALLY CREATE PARITY WITH OTHER
INSTITUTIONS, AND WE HOPE THAT
IF INDEED THERE HAS TO BE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL STIPENDS
THAT WE'LL BE DISCUSSING WITH
THE OPPOSITION OF WHAT THAT
NUMBER WILL BE. BUT YOU HAVE MY
SUPPORT IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE'D BE WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION ON LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL WAYS TO ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY. DO YOU HAVE
A MOTION? YOU DO NOT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. OKAY. SO MOVED. WE'LL
TAKE A. YES. SO MOVED. OKAY. WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL. GO AHEAD.
MOTIONS DO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I BECKER.
DODD DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLAZER. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. NILO
NILO I ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. WILK I. IT HAS EIGHT
VOTES, WHICH IS ENOUGH, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT ON CALL
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES WHEN THEY COME BACK.
OKAY. MY PLEASURE, MADAM CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO ALL YOUR WITNESSES TO
EVERYONE. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO. YOU READY? THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. AND THANKS FOR
LETTING HIM SNEAK IN. HE'D BEEN
HERE FOR A REALLY LONG TIME.
OKAY GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2622. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. MANY OF US HAVE COME
ACROSS CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THAT REQUIRE SKILLS BEYOND OUR
CAPABILITY. DESPITE THE
ABUNDANCE OF DO IT YOURSELF
HARDWARE STORES AND INFORMATION
AT OUR FINGERTIPS, WE MUST OFTEN
CALL ON THESE PROFESSIONALS FOR
GUIDANCE. AND I AM NOT
UNFAMILIAR WITH THIS KIND OF
WORK. WHEN I IMMIGRATED TO THIS
COUNTRY, I WORKED IN
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND STILL
ENJOY WORKING ON PROJECTS IN MY
FREE TIME. MANY PROFESSIONALS
WHO PERFORM THIS WORK ARE
IMMIGRANTS WITH UNIQUE, VALUABLE
SKILLS AND TRAITS. THEY MAY
OBTAIN A CONTRACTUAL LICENSE OR
CONDITIONALLY OPERATE WITHOUT A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE. THE MINOR
WORK EXEMPTION ALLOWS HANDYMEN
TO REMAIN EXEMPT FROM A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE, SO LONG AS
THE PROJECTS THEY TAKE ARE LESS
THAN $500, INCLUSIVE OF LABOR
AND MATERIALS, AND SO LONG AS
THEY ARE CASUAL, MINOR OR
INCONSEQUENTIAL, THESE $500 CAP
HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE 1998,
AND SEVERAL ISSUES HAVE ARISEN
BECAUSE OF THIS OUTDATED FIGURE.
FIRST, START THE ROCKETING COST
OF LABOR AND MATERIALS. MANY
SIMPLE PROJECTS, SUCH AS
SPINNING A FENCE, MAY EASILY
SURPASS $500, MEANING THAT
UNLICENSED PROFESSIONALS ARE
TAKING ON THESE SMALL JOBS.
ILLEGALLY LICENSED PROFESSIONALS
UNDER THOSE SAME MARKET
PRESSURES MAY TURN DOWN THESE
SMALLER JOBS BY INCREASING THE
MINOR WORK EXEMPTION TO $1,000.
AB 2622 ENSURES THAT THESE FOLKS
ARE ABLE TO BE HIRED LEGALLY AND
PURSUE WORK, KNOWING THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO CHARGE A REASONABLE
AMOUNT WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO HAVE
THESE SMALL JOBS ON THE RECORD,
THEY CAN BUILD A PORTFOLIO WHICH
MAY AFFORD THEM A PATHWAY INTO
LICENSURE. IMPORTANTLY THE BILL
PROVIDES SEVERAL CONDITIONS
THESE PROFESSIONALS MUST MEET IN
ORDER TO WORK AT THEIR HIGHER
AMOUNT. THEY ARE PROHIBITED FROM
HIRING EMPLOYEES. THEY ARE ALSO
PROHIBITED FROM PERFORMING ANY
PROJECTS FOR WHICH A BUILDING
PERMIT IS REQUIRED. THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN ENSURING
HANDYMEN CAN MAKE A LIVING WHILE
ALSO PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
HOPEFULLY INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF POTENTIAL LICENSEES. LASTLY,
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD MY THANKS TO
THE BUILDING TRADES FOR WORKING
WITH US TO FIND A PATH FORWARD
ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK
YOU AND I DO NOT HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES. OKAY. NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT.
SUPPORT, SIR. GO AHEAD. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS?
I WOULD. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
ASHBY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES, I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE ENGAGEMENT OF HIS STAFF
AND ALSO YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU DID
ON THIS BILL TO MOVE US TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM TODAY? WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT,
COME ON FORWARD. YOU WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES. WELL, GOOD
AFTERNOON, RICHARD MARX. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE PLUMBING, HEATING,
COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE CHANGES IN THE BILL. BUT
WHAT'S MISSING FROM THE BILL?
SENATOR ARCHULETA HAD A BILL. A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. SB 304,
THAT MADE TWO ADDITIONAL
CHANGES. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT CREATES A DICHOTOMY BECAUSE A
LICENSED CONTRACTOR IS SO QUICK
TO, LICENSURE BY THE CONTRACTOR
STATE LICENSE BOARD. THEY
SUBMIT, FINGERPRINTS TO VERIFY
THAT ANY CRIMINAL ACTIVITY IS
WEEDED OUT IF IT AFFECTS THEIR
ABILITY TO PERFORM GO INTO
PEOPLE'S HOMES. AND THEY'RE ALSO
REQUIRED TO HAVE WRITTEN
CONTRACTS AND A RIGHT TO RESCIND
THE CONTRACT. AND STOP THE WORK
FROM PROCEEDING. IF IT EXCEEDS
$500 AND IS LESS THAN $750. SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES, IS IT
CREATES A DICHOTOMY WHERE
ARGUABLY YOU ARE DEREGULATING
CONSTRUCTION WORK THAT'S UNDER
$1,000, BUT YOU ARE CREATING OR
YOU ARE EXTENDING THE SAME
OBLIGATIONS FOR LICENSED
CONTRACTORS FOR ANY WORK ABOVE
$500 AND A HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACTS THAT ARE UP TO $750.
SO WHAT WE HAVE REQUESTED SINCE
THE BILL WAS INTRODUCED IS
LANGUAGE SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS IN
SENATOR ARCHULETA'S BILL TO
MODERNIZE AND TO ADVANCE THOSE
TWO PROVISIONS IN 75, 1910 AND
14, TO BRING THOSE UP TO THE
SAME LEVELS THAT UNLICENSED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WILL NOW BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH. OKAY,
GREAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY? SEEING NO
ONE, I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DÍAS COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS,
SENATOR ARCHULETA? YES. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR
BRINGING THE BILL. HAVE YOU
HEARD? I PRESENTED MINE, TWO
YEARS AGO. AND OF COURSE, THE
COST OF MATERIAL, THE COST OF
EVERYTHING HAS GONE MUCH, MUCH
HIGHER. AND THIS THRESHOLD OF
$1,000, I DON'T SEE IT'S OUT OF
OUT OF LINE. AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. MOVE THE BILL, AND I
CONGRATULATE YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. THANK YOU.
WANT TO CLOSE? OH WAIT. HOLD ON.
SORRY. ONE MORE QUESTION, CAN
YOU CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ABOUT THE BOARD COMING ON
IN OPPOSITION, I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT. YEAH, THEY DID,
TELL US WHAT THEIR CONCERNS
WERE. WE ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. HAPPY TO
MEET WITH THEM. I BELIEVE THAT
IT'S JUST A TECHNICAL MINOR
ISSUE. IN MY PERSPECTIVE, WE CAN
INCREASE IT TO THE 1000. IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE US TO DO.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. OKAY. I JUST
THINK FOR A BILL BEING
OVERLOOKED BY THIS DEPARTMENT OR
BOARD, THEY SHOULD BE IN
SUPPORT. SO I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY AND THEN LOOK FORWARD
TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU. OKAY.
DO YOU WANT TO DO YOUR CLOTHES?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
ARCHULETA. WE'LL CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
HI, ASHBY. I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO GILL I ALVARADO GILL.
I'M SORRY YOU LOOKED AT ME. I
WAS LIKE THAT THAT WAS THAT WAS
THE WORST VOICE IMPRESSION I'VE
EVER HEARD OF. ALVARADO GILL.
ARE WE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
BE A WEEK OF MONDAYS? THAT'S
OKAY. LET'S TRY IT AGAIN. YOUR
NAME IS DODD. OKAY. ALVARADO.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BECKER. DODD DODD I.
THERE YOU GO. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO
NILO I ROTH SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
WILK WILK I THAT'S EIGHT, WE
WILL KEEP IT ON CALL, THOUGH.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S SEE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. COME ON.
FORWARD WHEN YOU'RE READY, GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT AB 2579. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
FIRST I WANT TO, BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE. AND WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
AB 2579 GRANTS BUILDING OWNERS
WITH THREE OR MORE MULTIFAMILY
DWELLING UNITS, A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION FOR EXTERIOR ELEVATED
ELEMENT INSPECTIONS. IN OTHER
WORDS, BALCONY INSPECTIONS.
INSPECTIONS WERE TO BE COMPLETED
BY JANUARY 1ST, 2025, AND
SUBSEQUENTLY EVERY SIX YEARS
AFTER. HOWEVER, CALIFORNIA
ISSUED A STATE OF EMERGENCY DUE
TO THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC. PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS HINDERED THE
ABILITY FOR INSPECTIONS THAT
NEEDED TO TAKE PLACE. PLANNING
AND SCHEDULING INSPECTIONS,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LACK OF
SPECIALIZED INSPECTOR WORKFORCE,
CAN TAKE UP TO FOUR MONTHS TO
ARRANGE. ONCE SCHEDULED. THESE
INSPECTIONS, WHICH CAN BE
INTRUSIVE TO THE BUILDING AND
THE APARTMENT, CAN TAKE UP TO
THREE WEEKS TO COMPLETE, MAKING
SURE THAT BALCONIES ARE NOT ONLY
INSPECTED AND ON, BUT ALSO ARE
SAFE IS CRUCIAL WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HAS. IS
MR. CHRIS KHN, ADVISOR ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MR. KONG. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, CHRIS KHN REPRESENTING THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. AND
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING IT TODAY. MY MEMBERS ARE
VERY COMMITTED TO THE INSPECTION
AND REPAIR PROGRAM SET UP BY
SENATOR HILL'S BILL A FEW YEARS
AGO, WE APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION
AND ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THERE
WERE DELAYS, AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IT RIGHT. SO AGAIN,
WE APPRECIATE AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? THE BILL. BILL. ALL
RIGHT. MOVED BY SENATOR
ALVARADO. GIL. SORRY, SENATOR
WILK, I HEARD HER FIRST. OKAY,
WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. DO YOU WANT
TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY? RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER I.
BECKER. AYE. DODD. DODD AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NYOLO
NILO. AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S TEN VOTES.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. SO IT'LL BE JUST
FINE, BUT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
IT ON CALL. MAKE SURE WE GET THE
VOTES OF OUR COLLEAGUES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBERS, HAVE A
GREAT REST OF THE WEEK. MOVING
ON, I SEE. OH YEP. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON IS HERE. WE CAN
TAKE UP FILE ITEM 11 AB 2774.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, AB 2774 ESTABLISHES THE
CHILD CARE FOR WORKING FAMILIES
TASK FORCE AND REQUIRES THAT THE
TASK FORCE SUBMIT A REPORT THAT
RECOMMENDS FUTURE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGIES AIMED AT ADDRESSING
CHALLENGES FACED BY WORKING
FAMILIES IN ACCESSING FLEXIBLE,
AFFORDABLE AND QUALITY CHILD
CARE OPTIONS. AFFORDABLE CHILD
CARE IS UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF
REACH FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS, TOO
MANY FAMILIES CONTINUE TO FALL
THROUGH WHAT WE CALL CARE GAPS,
WHICH JUST WITH JUST 14% OF THE
STATE'S ELIGIBLE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS HAVING ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE THAT ARE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS
OF FAMILIES THAT FALL VICTIM TO
THE CARE CLIFF. THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENS
WORKING MOTHERS, WHO OFTEN TAKE
ON CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WHEN FAMILIES CANNOT FIND OR
AFFORD CARE. IN ADDITION TO
THAT, I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
GREAT NEED TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE THAT CHILD CARE IS NOT
ONLY A SOCIAL OR WOMEN'S ISSUE,
BUT IT'S AN ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE
FOR THE GROWTH OF THE STATE.
CHILD CARE IS A POLICY ISSUE
THAT CUTS ACROSS MANY AREAS OF
PUBLIC INTEREST, INCLUDING
WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION,
ECONOMIC MOBILITY, PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND EVEN ENERGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT IS WHY WE
MUST EXPLORE THE NEED FOR
RENEWED INVESTMENTS IN CHILD
CARE AND SOLUTIONS AIMED AT
TACKLING THE CHILD CARE CRISIS
HEAD ON. I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR STATE HAS
UNDERTAKEN SIGNIFICANT AND
CRUCIAL EFFORTS, PARTICULARLY
THROUGH THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION AND THE GOVERNOR'S
MASTER PLAN ON EARLY CHILD CARE
AND EDUCATION. HOWEVER, THE
LANDSCAPE HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE COVID 19
PANDEMIC, AND THERE HAS NOT YET
BEEN A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON WORKING
FAMILIES OR THE EXAMINATION OF
CHILD CARE IN THE CONTEXT OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. SO, GIVEN
THE BUDGETARY CHANGES AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR MORE NEXT YEAR, WE
NEED A POST-COVID REVIEW AND
STAKEHOLDER CONVENING THAT
REVISITS CURRENT AND POTENTIAL
POLICIES UNDER THE NEW REALITY
OF OUR STATE DEFICIT AND THE
CHANGING ECONOMICS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES.
ADDRESSING CHILDCARE
AFFORDABILITY HELPS BUILD A
COMPETITIVE ECONOMY AND NEW WAYS
OF APPROACHING THE CARE CRISIS
IS BOTH BENEFICIAL FOR FAMILIES,
VITAL FOR BUSINESSES, AND
CRITICAL TO THE RECOVERY OF
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. AS THE STATE
GOES THROUGH ITS MULTI-YEAR
BUDGET DEFICIT. I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN THE
LANGUAGE IN AB 2774 TO CLARIFY
THE INTENT OF THE BILL, AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO EXISTING WORK
AND NOT DUPLICATIVE. I DO WANT
TO STATE THAT THE COMMITTEE,
STAFF AND LEADERSHIP THAT HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE IN PROVIDING
HELPING PROVIDE SOME DIRECTION
IN THAT AREA AND PUTTING US ON A
PATH TO IMPROVING THE BILL EVEN
MORE SO WITH ME TODAY, WE HAVE
DENEEN COBURN, CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THRIVING FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA, THROUGH THE CHAIR.
HI. GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE, SENATOR ASHBY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DENEEN COLBURN, REPRESENTING
THRIVING FAMILIES CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER 20 YEARS. I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION,
EVALUATION, STRENGTHENING,
EROSION, AND THE REBUILDING OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. AS YOUR
ANALYSIS NOTES, THERE'S QUITE A
BIT OF RESEARCH REGARDING THE
VALUE OF ACCESS TO QUALITY CHILD
CARE AND OUTCOMES. THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT THE VALUE OF QUALITY
CHILD CARE. RATHER, THIS BILL IS
ABOUT CONNECTING THE NEEDS OF
REAL WORKING FAMILIES THAT
REQUIRE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
AFTER SCHOOL HOURS AFTER 6 P.M.
AND ON THE WEEKENDS. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT CONSIDERING THE NEEDS
OF EMPLOYERS WHO MUST HAVE
STATIC WORKFORCE IN ORDER TO
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN. AB 2774
IS ABOUT CAPTURING THE ECONOMIC
MULTIPLIER THAT FOR EVERY $1
INVESTED IN CHILD CARE, THERE IS
BETWEEN 7 TO $13. THAT GOES BACK
INTO THE ECONOMY. MY MEMBERSHIP
OF COMMUNITY BASED COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
NONPROFITS UNDERSTAND THE
ECONOMICS OF ACCESSIBLE AND
ATTAINABLE CHILD CARE REQUIRED
IN A 24 HOUR ECONOMY. THAT IS
WHY MOST OF THESE AGENCIES ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR LOCAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. FINALLY,
LAST WEEK, THE US CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE KICKED OFF A
GROUNDBREAKING CHILD CARE
INNOVATION SUMMIT FOCUSED ON
CONNECTING CHILD CARE TO A
THRIVING ECONOMY. FURTHER, THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE COMMITTED
FUNDING TO BUSINESSES THAT
SUPPORT AND OFFER CHILD CARE. AB
2774 IS THE RIGHT BILL AT THE
RIGHT TIME TO BE TAKEN ON UNDER
THE UMBRELLA OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY?
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS ROSANNA CARAVAGGIO
ELLIOTT HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, BLAKE
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF CHILD
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL? HOW ABOUT FOLKS WHO
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ISSUE
CONCERNS. ALL RIGHT THEN SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DÍAS COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL? DID YOU
HEAR ME THAT TIME? I COULD HEAR
YOU THAT TIME MOVED. OKAY. I
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON THE
BILL. I AM PREPARED TO VOTE FOR
THE BILL TODAY TO KEEP YOU
MOVING FORWARD, I AM A FORMER
RECIPIENT OF CHILD ACTION AND A
HUGE ADVOCATE FOR CHILD CARE.
I'M NOT SURE, THOUGH, THAT THIS
IS ADDITIVE. I WORRY ABOUT TOO
MANY DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES IN
THE MIX. WE ALREADY HAVE THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL
THAT DOES ALL OF THE CHILD CARE
REVIEWS AND ANALYSIS OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
WHICH I THINK IS APPROPRIATELY
PLACED. AND THEN, OF COURSE,
THERE ARE ALL THE EFFORTS FOR
CHILD CARE AND EARLY LEARNING
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OUT OF
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION'S OFFICE. AND I'M
I'M NOT SURE IF GO-BIZ WOULD BE
ADDITIVE TO THAT IN THIS WAY.
AND SO MY ASK OF THE AUTHOR IS
TO KEEP A MINDSET ON THAT, THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING USE OF
DOLLARS FOR THE SAME PURPOSE AND
THAT IT DOES CONTINUE TO BE AN
ADDITIVE RESOURCE. GÓMEZ IS A
PRECIOUSLY OVERBURDENED AGENCY,
LIKE ALL OF OUR AGENCIES HERE.
AND WHILE CHILD CARE IS
ABSOLUTELY A CRITICAL PART OF
BUSINESS AND ESPECIALLY SMALL
BUSINESS, I DON'T KNOW THAT
HAVING THEM INVOLVED IN
DISCUSSIONS AROUND CHILD CARE IS
AS PARAMOUNT AS HAVING THEM
POTENTIALLY DO POLICIES TO WORK
WITH BUSINESSES TO BE ADDITIVE
ABOUT CHILD CARE. SO MY ASK OF
YOU TODAY IS JUST THAT. YOU KEEP
A KEEN EYE ON THAT AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. SO WE DON'T DUPLICATE
DOLLARS FOR THE SAME OUTCOMES.
ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE A MOTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I SHARE
THOSE SENTIMENTS AS WELL. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. AND THEY ARE WELL
TAKEN. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WILK. LET ME
REITERATE, SENATOR WILK, BECAUSE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. OKAY. WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
HI. ASHBY. I WHEN I, WHEN I
ALVARADO. GILL I ALVARADO GILL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER
BECKER I DODD. EGGMAN LAZAR
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO I NEAL
I ROTH SMALLWOOD CUEVAS WILK
WILK. I HAS EIGHT VOTES, WHICH
IS ENOUGH, BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL HERE FROM OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES AT THE END. THANK YOU
MADAM. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE
LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. AND COLLEAGUES, WHILE WE
HAVE A BREAK IN THE ACTION HERE,
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON HAS REACHED OUT AND ASKED
AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST, TO PULL
FILE ITEM TWO AB 2862. AGAIN,
THAT IS THE AUTHORS REQUEST TO
PULL ITEM TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON AB 2862. SO THAT WILL
COME OFF OF OUR FILE AS OF NOW.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
JUST IN TIME. WE'RE READY TO
HEAR FROM YOU. FILE ITEM TEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. THIS
BILL THAT IS BEFORE YOU IS ONE
OF THE TOP RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON
LITHIUM EXTRACTION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS YOU ALL KNOW,
THE SALTON SEA REGION HAS ONE OF
THE LARGEST LITHIUM DEPOSITS ON
THE CONTINENT. THIS BILL WOULD
HELP STREAMLINE AND ACCELERATE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN A REGION
THAT HAS SUFFERED FROM A LONG,
LONG, LONG DECADE OF HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY WILL IT
UPLIFT THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES, BUT ALSO BEGIN TO
GENERATE THE RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO INVEST IN MANY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES, ALONG WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
PEOPLE FACE OUT THERE WITH ME
TODAY ARE TWO INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE COMMUNITY, CHRISTIAN TORRES,
REPRESENTING COMITÉ CIVICO DEL
VALLE AND SILVIA PAZ FROM
ALIANZA COACHELLA VALLEY, WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE LITHIUM
VALLEY COMMISSION AND DEVELOPED
A STRATEGY FOR THESE EFFORTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD AND
SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS WITH US.
THANK YOU. SYLVIA PAZ. GREW UP
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY. I AM
ALSO THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ALIANZA COACHELLA
VALLEY THAT IS WORKING TO
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESIDENTS WHO CALL THE SALTON
SEA REGION HOME. I CHAIRED THE
LITHIUM VALLEY COMMISSION DUE TO
THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THAT A
NEW INDUSTRY CAN HAVE IN AN AREA
THAT FACES A DEPRESSED ECONOMY
AS WELL AS POOR ENVIRONMENTAL
AND HEALTH OUTCOMES. THE LIGHT,
THE LITHIUM VALLEY COMMISSION
MET FOR ABOUT TWO YEARS. WE
ENGAGED WITH RESIDENTS, TRIBES,
INDUSTRY, GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES AND OTHER
EXPERTS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES OF
THE LITHIUM INDUSTRY IN THE
MAJORITY OF OUR CONVERSATIONS,
WE HEARD OF A DESIRE FOR A
LITHIUM INDUSTRY THAT BENEFITED
BOTH ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY. OUR SALTON SEA
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO DISCUSSED
THE CHALLENGES THAT OUR REGION
FACES AND THE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO CREATE
CONDITIONS FOR THIS INDUSTRY TO
BE MORE THAN AN EXTRACTIVE
INDUSTRY. DUE TO THE
MISALIGNMENT OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY, THE PALO VERDE VALLEY
AND IMPERIAL VALLEY INTO
ECONOMIC REGIONS THAT ARE
ECONOMICALLY, GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY DISTINCT, WE ARE
AT A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE TO
ATTAIN THE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WE NEED. SO FOR THESE
REASONS, THE COMMISSION DID MAKE
A RECOMMENDATION FOR US TO BE
DESIGNATED AS OUR OWN ECONOMIC
REGION. AND AB 2757 ACCOMPLISHES
THIS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
COMMITTEE DEL VALLE, CO-SPONSORS
OF AB 2757, A MEASURE THAT WOULD
DESIGNATE THE SOUTHEAST
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC REGION FOR
ALIGNING STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS TO BENEFIT COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY LITHIUM AND ANOTHER
MINERAL EXTRACTION AND CLEAN
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT. THE MEASURE
ALSO ALLOWS FOR REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO CREATE A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE SALTON SEA REGION, AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON LITHIUM EXTRACTION
IN CALIFORNIA. THE PURPOSE OF AB
2757 IS TO CULTIVATE, STIMULATE,
AND AGGREGATE TARGETED
INVESTMENTS BY THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA'S
SOUTHEASTERN DESERT REGION,
WHICH HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
OVERLOOKED AND LEFT BEHIND BY
THE STATE'S EXISTING ECONOMIC
PLANNING AND FUNDING ACTIVITIES.
AB 2757 IS INTENDED TO ENHANCE
THE COUNTY'S ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOLBOX BY
AUTHORIZING THE SALTON SEA
REGION TO MORE AUTHENTICALLY
ALIGN COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST
AND ATTRACT PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
CAPITAL MORE EFFECTIVELY AS
CO-SPONSORS REPRESENTING THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES RESIDING
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY, LITHIUM
VALLEY, AND THE SALTON SEA
REGION. COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. ARE
THERE OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2757 TODAY? COME
ON. FORWARD AND GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. MADAM
CHAIR JEFF NEAL, REPRESENTING
THE COUNTY OF IMPERIAL. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE, MADAM
CHAIR. GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF COACHELLA, AS WELL AS
THE SALTON SEA AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AARON WOOLLEY, ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF VÌ
LOS AMIGOS DE LA COMUNIDAD. AND
AS A PROXY FOR LA COOPERATIVA
CAMPESINA DE CALIFORNIA, ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IN THE ROOM, LEAD OR OTHERWISE,
SEEING NO ONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE DAIS? COLLEAGUES WITH
QUESTIONS. SENATOR WILK, BUT YOU
DO HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
ARCHULETA. YEAH. I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY MORE TIMES WE'LL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS, BUT I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS, ON THIS
WHOLE PROJECT. THIS IS THIS IS
SO EXCITING. IT'S GOING TO JUST,
THEY OFTEN SAY THAT GEOGRAPHY IS
DESTINY. AND IT'S HELD THIS
REGION BACK. BUT WITH THIS
DISCOVERY AND WITH THE
INVESTMENTS BEING MADE AND THE
POLICIES THAT YOU'RE LAYING OUT
IS GOING TO JUST ENERGIZE THIS
WHOLE REGION, AND IT'S GOING TO
CREATE PROSPERITY FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE. SO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY, AND THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS. ALL
RIGHT. YOU HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? JUST THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE ANALYSIS.
AND I'M SURE THERE WAS NO PUN
INTENDED THERE WITH THE
ENERGIZING THE REGION, I WANT TO
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE WITNESSES REALLY GOT INTO
THE DETAILS OF WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT. JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT. VERY
GOOD. YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ARCHULETA. WE'LL CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY. Ã ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN
NGUYEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. Ã
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER BECKER.
AYE. DODD. EGGMAN GLASER.
MENGIBAR. NILO NEAL. AYE. ROTH.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK. WILK.
AYE SEVEN. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
SEVEN VOTES FOR NOW, WHICH IS
ENOUGH. BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES
WHEN THEY GET BACK. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
YOU WANT TO SIT DOWN UP FRONT.
OKAY, YOU CAN IF YOU WANT TO SIT
AT THE TABLE, YOU'RE WELCOME TO
HALF OF OUR AGENDA. I'M NOT
ALLOWED TO MAKE FUN OF HIM
BECAUSE I DID THE SAME THING TO
HIS COMMITTEE. HE'S PRESENTING A
PETRIE-NORRIS BILL FIRST. THIS
ISN'T YOUR BILL. ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUE'S BILL. IF THAT'S
OKAY. THAT SOUNDS GREAT.
PRESENT. THIS IS GOING TO BE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, WHICH IS
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. SO WE WILL HEAR
FROM YOU ON THAT FIRST. AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE INTO ALL THE
COMMITTEE BILLS THERE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS, I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 2559 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS TO HELP STREAMLINE
THE EV CHARGER, PERMITTING
PROCESS. GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
ARE PROJECTED TO NEED 2.1
MILLION EV CHARGERS BY 2035 TO
MEET INCREASING DEMAND, IT IS
VITAL THAT WE ENSURE PERMITTING
FOR THESE CHARGERS IS SMOOTH.
UNFORTUNATELY EV SERVICE
PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO FACE
DELAYS IN THEIR PERMITTING
REQUESTS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS. AB 2559 SEEKS TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS BY
REQUIRING GO-BIZ TO DEVELOP A
REPORTING PLATFORM WHERE EV
SERVICE PROVIDERS CAN LOG ANY
ISSUES THEY HAVE WITH A LOCAL
JURISDICTION. THE BILL ALSO
CODIFIES A PERMIT STREAM LEADING
SPECIALIST AT GO-BIZ TO
EXPEDITE, PERMITTING AND
IDENTIFY PERMIT STREAMLINING
BARRIERS. THIS WILL GIVE GO-BIZ
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
IDENTIFY OBSTACLES AND
CHALLENGES TO IMPLEMENTING THESE
CHARGING STATIONS, AND GET DOWN
TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF DELAYS. I
HOPE NO ONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS,
AND I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
INTRODUCE NICOLE HUTCHINSON ON
BEHALF OF CALSTART. THANK YOU,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, NICOLE HUTCHINSON AND
ON BEHALF OF CALSTART, A GLOBAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO PROMOTING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
FOR HER COMMITMENT TO EXPEDITING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDOUT AND FOR
AUTHORING AB 2559 AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN DESCRIBED,
THE BILL IS INTENDED TO HELP
EXPEDITE PERMITTING FOR ZEV
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SHED LIGHT ON
THE CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS
ASSOCIATED WITH PERMITTING. WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL HELP
IDENTIFY CAUSES FOR PERMITTING
DELAYS AND HELP US TOWARD OUR
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS. THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
COME ON, FORWARD MEGAN
MICKELBERG HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE EV CHARGING
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. BETTE
FRANKEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, AARON KUNZ
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GREAT RICHARD
MARKSON, FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL ON ANY LEVEL? OKAY.
SEEING NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS REALLY HARD QUESTIONS
ONLY, SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES. AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
HYDROGEN AND WE HAVE OUR ISSUES
AS WELL. AND I THINK THIS IS
GREAT. CAN YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON SOME OF THE, I
GUESS, WALLS YOU'VE RUN INTO
THAT CAUSED THE BILL TO COME
FORWARD? AS I SAID, THE
HYDROGEN, SECTORS ALSO HAVE
THESE ISSUES AS WELL. AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THAT. BUT GIVE US SOME IDEA OF
WHAT YOUR OBSTACLES HAVE BEEN.
SURE. AND SO THIS BILL IS
TECHNOLOGY AGNOSTIC. SO HYDROGEN
IS ALSO COVERED. SO IT'S ZEV
INFRASTRUCTURE BROADLY. SO BOTH
HYDROGEN AS WELL AS BATTERY
ELECTRIC CHARGING, SO I THINK
THE I THINK THE BIG MOTIVATION
FOR THIS BILL IS THAT TO DATE,
WE KNOW THERE ARE PERMITTING
CHALLENGES AND ALL OF IT IS
ANECDOTAL, WHETHER IT'S THERE'S
A LOT OF FINGER POINTING THAT
GOES ON Þ, IT'S THE HJS Ó, IT'S
THE ESPS Þ. IT'S ZONING. OH, WE
DON'T HAVE CAPACITY. AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE OF AN ISSUE, BUT NOT A
LOT OF HARD DATA TO HELP US TAKE
THE NEXT STEP, WHETHER IT'S
ENFORCEMENT, GIVING GO-BIZ THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE PRIOR
LEGISLATION. SO AB 970. AB 1236
BEFORE THAT. SO THIS BILL IS
SORT OF A FACT FINDING BILL TO
IDENTIFY THE SCOPE AND THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT FOLKS ARE
RUNNING INTO. WHAT IS IT
SPECIFICALLY? THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE A MOTION? YOU MADE THE
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. THERE
ARCHULETA MAKES THE MOTION. YOU
WANT TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS. VERY GOOD BILL. I
WISH I AUTHORED MYSELF. ALL
RIGHT, TAKE THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER
BECKER I DODD. EGGMAN LAZAR.
MENGIBAR NILO NILO I ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK WILK. AYE. OKAY.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES, SO IT'S
ENOUGH. BUT WE WILL PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE REMAINDER OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. OKAY, BEFORE WE
START HERE, I JUST WANT TO SAY
TO FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
BUILDING, OTHER SENATORS, WE ARE
STARTING WITH OUR LAST AUTHOR,
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
WHO HAS EIGHT BILLS, WHICH ARE
COMMITTEE BILLS. SO IF YOU ARE
IN THE BUILDING AND YOU ARE A
SENATOR ON BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, NOW
WOULD BE A GREAT TIME TO MAKE
YOUR WAY DOWN TO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM 2100 TO JOIN US.
ALL RIGHT. MR. BERMAN, LET'S GO.
THANK YOU. CHAIR ASHBY AND CHAIR
ASHBY AND SENATORS, THIS WILL BE
MY LONGEST PRESENTATION OF THE
DAY TODAY. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 2164, WHICH WILL CLARIFY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA TO REQUIRE
APPLICANTS AND PHYSICIANS TO
SELF DISCLOSE CONDITIONS THAT DO
NOT IMPAIR THEIR ABILITY TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE SAFELY,
INCLUDING DISORDERS FOR WHICH
THEY ARE RECEIVING TREATMENT.
WHEN OUR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
STRUGGLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND OTHER CONDITIONS,
WE WANT THEM TO SEEK OUT HELP
DURING THE MEDICAL BOARD'S MOST
RECENT SUNSET REVIEW, IT WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
DOCTORS AND MEDICAL STUDENTS
SOMETIMES FEEL THAT THEY CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN COUNSELING OR
RECOVERY PROGRAMS FOR FEAR OF
JEOPARDIZING THEIR LICENSE, EVEN
IF THEY ARE CONFIDENT THAT THEY
CAN STILL PRACTICE MEDICINE
SAFELY. AB 2164 WILL MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT APPLICANTS ONLY NEED
TO DISCLOSE DISORDERS OR
CONDITIONS THAT POSE A RISK TO
THEIR PATIENTS, AND THAT THEY
WILL NOT BE PUNISHED FOR GETTING
THE ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. WITH
ME TODAY ARE THE CO-SPONSORS OF
THE BILL, MATT LEGGETT WITH SEIU
, CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL AND
DOCTOR DANA ISAACS, MD, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, WELCOME. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES WHEN YOU ARE
READY. ALL RIGHT. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR DANA ISAACS. I'M A
HEMATOLOGY ONCOLOGY FELLOW
PHYSICIAN SERVING THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY AT UC DAVIS. I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
WHO IS CO-SPONSORING AB 2164.
THIS BILL WOULD BE ONE BIG STEP
IN REDUCING THE STIGMA AROUND
PHYSICIANS SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THIS ISSUE IS NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART. AS A DOCTOR
TREATING PATIENTS WITH CANCER.
CURRENTLY, THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSING
APPLICATION REQUIRES US TO
DISCLOSE OUR MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THIS MANDATORY
DISCLOSURE WILL NOT ACHIEVE ITS
INTENDED GOAL OF IDENTIFYING
PHYSICIANS WHO MAY POSE A RISK
TO PATIENT SAFETY. MENTAL HEALTH
IS A COMPLEX AND NUANCED ISSUE,
AND A BLANKET DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENT FAILS TO ACCOUNT FOR
INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
NEEDS. INSTEAD, IT CREATES A
CULTURE OF STIGMA AND
DISCRIMINATION, FURTHER
DISCOURAGING US FROM SEEKING
HELP IN PERPETUATING MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION. PHYSICIANS
MAY EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND REQUIRE
CONFIDENTIAL TREATMENT AND
SUPPORT. HOWEVER, THE FEAR OF
MANDATORY DISCLOSURE COULD DETER
THEM FROM SEEKING HELP AND
LEADING TO INCREASED BURNOUT,
STRESS, AND IMPAIRED PATIENT
CARE. MY MEDICAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS HAVE INCORPORATED
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE THE PERVASIVE
TRAUMA THAT WE EXPERIENCE
THROUGHOUT MY TRAINING, I HAVE
OFTEN SOUGHT THESE RESOURCES.
ONE DISTRESSING MEMORY WAS
LOSING TEN PATIENTS IN A SINGLE
WEEK IN THE INTENSIVE CARE UNIT,
WATCHING MY PATIENTS DIE.
DESPITE MY BEST EFFORTS HAS LEFT
A LASTING IMPACT ON ME. WE CARE
DEEPLY FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES
ON THE FRONT LINES, SO I URGE
YOU TO PLEASE DO YOUR PART IN
TAKING CARE OF US AS WELL. BY
PROMOTING A CULTURE OF
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORT TO
BETTER ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES WITHIN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY. THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THE WELL-BEING OF BOTH
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS, HELP US
REDUCE THE STIGMA OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE FOR DOCTORS BY
VOTING YES ON AB 2164. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND THANKS FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ALL RIGHT. GO
AHEAD, GOOD AFTERNOON, MATT
LAUER ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THE BILL TODAY, THIS IS
AN ISSUE. I APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE IN THE
PAST, AND THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND HIS STAFF.
IT'S ONE WHERE REALLY SEE THIS
AS A STEP FORWARD IN TRYING TO
IMPROVE THE CULTURE OF MEDICINE,
WHERE FOR TOO LONG THERE WAS TOO
MUCH OF A STIGMA OF, HEY, DON'T
JEOPARDIZE YOUR FUTURE, DON'T GO
SEEK THE TREATMENT THAT YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO OR THAT YOU WOULD
NEED. AND SO CAUSING THIS STIGMA
IN MEDICINE IN PARTICULAR, HAS
CAUSED THE RATES OF SUICIDE FOR,
MALE PHYSICIANS AND FEMALE
PHYSICIANS TO BE TWICE THAT OF
THE GENERAL POPULATION. SUICIDE
IS A LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
MALE PHYSICIANS AND FOR WOMEN
PHYSICIANS. IT IS THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH. SO
SOMETHING REALLY SERIOUS. WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TOO MANY
INCIDENTS LIKE THAT TO HAPPEN
IN, THE MEDICAL FIELD NOW. AND
SO WE SEE THIS BILL AS THAT STEP
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO,
DESTIGMATIZE BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS CARE, PARTICULARLY DURING
THE COVID PANDEMIC WHEN WE ARE
ALL IN SUCH A CRISIS POINT,
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THAT MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT IS CRITICAL. AND
SO I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL BRINGING THIS ONE
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? GO AHEAD. CLIFTON WILSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. CHEN CHASE, ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT AARON
BOWEN WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT PAUL
SIMMONS WITH CALIFORNIA PIER
WATCH IN SUPPORT ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SEEING NO ONE WILL COME
BACK TO THE DAIS? COLLEAGUES, DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL? ALL
RIGHT. MOVED BY, SENATOR EGGMAN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. GREAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR EGGMAN, AND
WE'LL CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GILL. Ã. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. LASER AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NHIÀU.
NHIÀU AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK. WILK. AYE IF TEN. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, THAT'S TEN. IT'S
ENOUGH. WE'LL STILL KEEP IT ON
CALL, THOUGH, BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COUPLE MORE MEMBERS OUT. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
NEXT UP, AB 2688. ALL RIGHT,
SPEAKING OF DOCTORS, AB 2688 IS
A TECHNICAL CLEANUP MEASURE THAT
CLARIFIES THAT ANY MEMBER OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA MAY
BE REMOVED ONLY BY THE AUTHORITY
THAT APPOINTED THAT MEMBER FOR
CONTINUED NEGLECT OF DUTIES
REQUIRED BY LAW, OR FOR
INCOMPETENCE OR UNPROFESSIONAL
OR DISHONORABLE CONDUCT.
PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA RELY ON INDEPENDENT
AND THOUGHTFUL MEMBERSHIPS ON
EACH OF THE REGULATORY BOARDS
ESTABLISHED TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC, BUT THE MEDICAL PRACTICE
ACT IS NOT CLEAR THAT AN
APPOINTING AUTHORITY MAY ONLY
REMOVE ITS OWN APPOINTED MEMBERS
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD. CLARIFYING
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THERE IS
NO UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE RIGHTS
AND AUTONOMY OF THE SEPARATE,
CO-EQUAL BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
WITH POWER TO MAKE APPOINTMENTS
TO THIS IMPORTANT BOARD. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. NO LEAD WITNESSES, NO
LEAD WITNESSES ON THIS ONE. ALL
RIGHT. ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION, BRING IT BACK TO THE
DÍAS COLLEAGUES MOVED BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS GOING TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT. WE'LL CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I. WHEN?
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL A ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER DODD.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. NEELO. AYE. NILA. AYE. ROTH
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK
AYE. ALL RIGHT. ALSO HAS TEN,
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL NEXT
UP, 3054 AB 3054. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATORS. AB
3054 WOULD EXTEND EXISTING
PROHIBITIONS AGAINST STATE
CANNABIS OFFICIALS HAVING
FINANCIAL INTERESTS OR
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO ADDITIONAL
APPOINTED OFFICIALS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
CALIFORNIANS RELY ON STATE
CANNABIS OFFICIALS TO FAIRLY AND
UNBIASEDLY ADMINISTER AND
ENFORCE OUR CANNABIS LAWS, AND
AB 3054 WILL PROVIDE ADDED
CONFIDENCE THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
BEING REGULATED FAIRLY AND
IMPARTIALLY. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NO LEAD
WITNESSES ON THIS ONE EITHER.
NO, NOT THIS ONE. ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK TODAY? ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT.
COLLEAGUES, MOVE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN, WE HAVE A MOTION. WE'LL
CALL THE ROLL. OH, YEAH? DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE MR. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SORRY MOTION IS DUE.
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO.
GIL. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEELO. AYE. NILA.
AYE ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE WILK AYE.
WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT. ALSO TEN.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. LET'S GO
TO FILE ITEM 16, WHICH IS AB
3251. THIS IS YOUR ACCOUNTANCY.
GREAT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AB 3251 IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR
THE BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE FOR
THE BOARD BY FOUR YEARS AND
MAKES ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND POLICY REFORMS IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUES RAISED DURING
THE BOARD'S SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS. SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL
ALLOWS THE BOARD TO NOTIFY
LICENSEES OF RULE CHANGES VIA
EMAIL AND TO RECEIVE AN
APPLICANT'S TRANSCRIPTS FROM A
DUAL DEGREE PROGRAM
ELECTRONICALLY. THIS AUTHORIZES
THE BOARD TO GRANT RETIRED
STATUS TO A LICENSEE WHOSE
PRACTICE IS PERMANENTLY
RESTRICTED, ENSURES ACCOUNTING
FIRM OWNERS HAVE THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITIES AS THEIR
EMPLOYEES. MAKES CERTAIN THE
BOARD HAS ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS
NECESSARY FOR AN INVESTIGATION,
AND STRENGTHENS THE BOARD'S
OVERSIGHT OF REGISTERED
ACCOUNTING FIRMS. I APPRECIATE
THE COLLABORATION FROM THE BOARD
, STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMITTEE,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME TODAY IS
THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE OFFICER,
DOMINIC FRANCELLA, TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, MR. FRANCIA, DID YOU
WANT TO JUST AT LEAST INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND THEN BE AVAILABLE
IF THERE'S QUESTIONS? OR DO YOU
HAVE COMMENTS? YES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, DOMINIC FRANZEL,
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY, AND I'D
LIKE TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION
TO CHAIR ASHBY FOR BECOMING A
PRINCIPAL AUTHOR, OUR PRINCIPAL
COAUTHOR ON THE BILL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE SUNSET. AND
I'M HERE TO DO MY BEST TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ALL
RIGHT. VERY GOOD. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT?
GO AHEAD. JASON FOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS. WE WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY ON THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS, AND A LOT OF THE
LANGUAGE AND CLEANUP THAT WERE
INCORPORATED INTO THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT, ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE DÍAS COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR EGGMAN MOVES THE BILL.
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY. AYE WHEN I WHEN I I'LL
WRITE A GILL AL VIÆT. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA A ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. DODD EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NHIÀU.
AYE. NHIÀU AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
ALSO TEN ON THAT ONE. YOU'RE ON
A ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LET'S
KEEP GOING. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. ON CALL AB 3252 AB 3252
IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD, WHICH REGULATES
COURTROOM STENOGRAPHERS AND
DEPOSITION REPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE SUNSET DATE FOR BOTH THE
BOARD AND THE TRANSCRIPT AND THE
TRANSCRIPT. REIMBURSEMENT FUND
PROGRAM BY FOUR YEARS, AND IT
REQUIRES REPORTERS TO STATE
THEIR LICENSE NUMBER BEFORE
BEGINNING A PROCEEDING. AND IT
MAKES ADDITIONAL REFORMS IN
RESPONSE TO THE BOARD'S SUNSET
REVIEW. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY COMMITTEE STAFF
TO DRAFT ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH AN ASSOCIATE COURT
REPORTER LICENSE, AND I ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS WITH ME TODAY
TO HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE AND TO PROVIDE ANY
COMMENTS SHE WANTS TO. IS THE
BOARD'S EXECUTIVE OFFICER, AVON
FENNER. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, AND
THANKS FOR TAKING THE AMENDS TO
MISS FENNER. GOOD AFTERNOON.
YVONNE FENNER, EXECUTIVE OFFICER
WITH COURT REPORTERS BOARD, HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ON FORWARD? GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ED HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPOSITION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL? GREAT SEEING NO ONE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS
COLLEAGUES. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
EGGMAN MOVES THE BILL. CALL THE
ROLL. OH, DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE,
MR. CHAIRMAN? RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE NGUYEN.
ALVARADO. GILL Ã. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
AYE. BECKER. DODD. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE.
NEELO. NEILA. AYE ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. WILK. WILK. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT ONE HAS NINE. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. MOVE TO THE
NEXT ONE. HERE. AB 3253. THIS IS
THE ENGINEERS. LAND SURVEYORS,
GEOLOGISTS. THIS IS THE LONGEST
ACRONYM, I THINK, OF ALL OF
THEM. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS. AB 3253 IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS, LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE FOR
THE BOARD BY FOUR YEARS AND
MAKES ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND POLICY REFORMS IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUES RAISED DURING
THE BOARD'S SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS, SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL
STRENGTHENS THE ABILITY FOR THE
BOARD TO ENFORCE AGAINST
FRAUDULENT TITLE USAGE. CONFORMS
CALIFORNIA ENGINEERING LAW TO BE
IN LINE WITH RECENT NATIONAL AND
UK RECIPROCITY AGREEMENTS, AND
REQUIRES PROOF OF INSURANCE AND
CONTRACTS BETWEEN LICENSEES AND
CLIENTS, AMONG OTHER CHANGES. I
WANT TO THANK THE BOARD, STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR THE ENGAGED
DIALOG THROUGHOUT THIS SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS AND FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE BILL. AND
WITH ME TODAY IS RICK MOORE,
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE BOARD,
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANKS MR.
MOORE, WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS? YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. APPRECIATE
ALL THE SUPPORT FROM BOTH
COMMITTEES ON THIS, AND
DEFINITELY THE COLLABORATION
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ONE. AND WE
PRONOUNCE IT BILLS. WE KEEP THE
G SILENT. THERE WE GO. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
SIR. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
COME ON. FORWARD. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, JASON
SCHMELZER HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA, NEVADA CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND LAND SURVEYORS
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO A
CALIFORNIA, OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL, WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT ISSUES RELATED
TO UNLICENSED PRACTICE OF LAND
SURVEYING COULDN'T BE ADDRESSED.
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR,
YOUR COMMITTEES AND THE BOARD,
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING NEXT YEAR AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS GV AYERS. I REPRESENT THE
SILENT G, THE ASSOCIATION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENGINEERING
GEOLOGISTS, AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR BEING HERE
. IT'S OKAY. HI, I'M CHRISTINA
GALLAGHER. I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. WE HAVE A SUPPORT WITH
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON THIS
BILL TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG OF
APPLICATIONS FOR CIVIL
ENGINEERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
GOOD AFTERNOON. RICHARD MARKSON,
FOR THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
CIVIL ENGINEERS IN SUPPORT,
ALTHOUGH APPARENTLY, WHEN THE
BILL IS PASSED, I WILL NO LONGER
BE ABLE TO REFER TO MYSELF AS A
LOBBYIST AND A GEOPHYSICIST IN
TRAINING. SO BUT I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT THAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SACRIFICE. OKAY. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IN THE ROOM, SEEING NO
ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DÍAS COLLEAGUES? SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES THE BILL. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE.
PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY, I NGUYEN I NGUYEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA.
AYE BECKER. DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. LASER. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE NEELO.
AYE. NEELO. AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS TEN AS WELL, MR.
BERMAN. SO WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL AND MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE.
JUST FOR THOSE OF YOU IN THE
BUILDING WHO ARE SENATORS ON THE
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE,
WE ARE ON OUR LAST TWO BILLS.
WE'LL GET THROUGH THESE AND WE
WILL THEN GO THROUGH OUR ROLL
ONE TIME. SO MR. BERMAN, FILE
ITEM 19, AB 3254. ARE YOU READY?
YEAH, I'M READY AS I'LL EVER BE.
AB 3254 IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR
THE CEMETERY AND FUNERAL.
FUNERAL BUREAU, WHICH REGULATES
THE DEATH CARE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE BUREAU
BY FOUR YEARS. REQUIRES THE
BUREAU TO MEET WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO DISCUSS SOLUTIONS TO
ABANDONED CEMETERY ISSUES.
PROVIDES THE BUREAU WITH MORE
INFORMATION FROM CEMETERIES AS
PART OF ITS ENDOWMENT CARE
EFFICIENCY STUDY, AND MAKES
ADDITIONAL REFORMS AND CHANGES
IN RESPONSE TO THE BUREAU'S
SUNSET REVIEW. AND WITH ME TODAY
FOR COMMENTS AND TO HELP ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE BILL IS BUREAU CHIEF GINA
SANCHEZ. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. MISS SANCHEZ, YOU WANT
TO MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS? IT'S
OKAY. THEY'LL TURN IT ON FOR
YOU. GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR, I'M
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE. I
APPRECIATE THE, THE SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL AND THE COLLABORATION
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS, SO I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? OKAY. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, JERRY DESMONDE WITH
THE CEMETERY AND MORTUARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE BUREAU.
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS ABANDONED CEMETERIES AND
PREVENT THEM FROM HAPPENING, AND
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATIONS
THAT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S IS
MAKING TO THE BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BUREAU HAS THE RIGHT
RESOURCES AND ENGAGES THE
PROFESSIONAL TRUSTEE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, MADAM
CHAIR. CHRIS MICHELI, ON BEHALF
OF SCA, CALIFORNIA FUNERAL
SERVICES, WITH THE SAME POSITION
AS OUR TRADE ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE. IS THERE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THE
ROOM? SEEING NO ONE, WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES,
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. MOVED BY.
SENATOR GLAZIER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
I ASHBY I WIN, I WIN, I
ALVARADO. GILL I ALVARADO. GILL
I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER
DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLAZER
LAZAR I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NIELLO I NEIL I ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
PHOEBUS SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK
WILK I. ALL RIGHT, THAT ONE HAS
TWO AS WELL. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL LAST. BILL, THIS IS THE
LAST BILL UP IN BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN ROOM 2100. SO WE
WOULD URGE ANY SENATORS ON THE
COMMITTEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE ROLL TO MAKE
THEIR WAY DOWN HERE. NOW, IT'D
BE GREAT. ALL RIGHT, MR. BERMAN,
LET ME START, MADAM CHAIR, JUST
BY SAYING WHAT A PLEASURE IT'S
BEEN HANGING OUT WITH YOU ALL
TODAY, AND I RESPECTFULLY LIMIT
TO THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT ONE
PERSON PRESENTS. JUST REMEMBER,
I TOOK ALL OF OURS OVER THERE
LAST WEEK, SO, I RESPECTFULLY
PRESENT SB 3255, THE SUNSET BILL
FOR THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL
NURSING AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS. THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE BOARD BY FOUR YEARS, CREATES
A RETIRED LICENSE CATEGORY,
MAKES VARIOUS IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE SCHOOL, APPROVAL PROCESS,
AND MAKES OTHER CHANGES
REQUESTED BY THE BOARD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE NO LEAD
WITNESSES, BUT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
TO THIS ITEM TO AB 3255, SEEING
NO ONE IN SUPPORT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT, BACK TO
THE DAIS. ALL RIGHT. I THINK I
HEARD SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
THERE. WE'LL TAKE THAT,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN, YOU WANT
TO SAY ANYTHING HERE?
RESPECTFULLY, YOUR BIG FINAL
MOMENT, IT'S THAT WAS VERY
ANTICLIMACTIC, BUT. ALL RIGHT,
WELL, APPRECIATE IT, Y'ALL. YOU
DID A GREAT JOB, THOUGH. RUNNING
THROUGH THOSE EIGHT BILLS. NICE.
AND NINE, ACTUALLY. AND THANK
YOU FOR TAKING A LITTLE WHILE
EARLIER SINCE I WAS RUNNING
LATE. YEAH, WE DID THE BEST WE
COULD TO DELAY JUST FOR YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU. GREAT. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE THE ROLL.
OKAY. MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY Ã ASHBY. I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BECKER
BECKER I DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN I
GLASER. GLASER. I MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NILO I NILO I ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMILED. CUEVAS
I WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THAT
HAS 11 AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL AS WELL. AGAIN. THANK YOU,
SUMMER BERMAN. PLEASURE TO DO
ALL OF THESE BILLS WITH YOU.
IT'S REALLY FUN. WE HAVE A GOOD
TIME. GREAT PARTNER. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO
WAIT FOR JUST A MOMENT, SEE IF
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF COLLEAGUES.
MISS MASON, COME UP HERE FOR A
SECOND.
OKAY. I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE TIME.
I'LL DO IT TWICE, SO I'M GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL TWO
TIMES. HERE WE'LL GO ONCE
THROUGH SO WE CAN GET THESE
MEMBERS OUT AND RESPECT THEIR
TIME THAT HAVE BEEN SITTING HERE
WITH US ALL DAY. ALL RIGHT. FILE
ITEM ONE. GIBSON, THIS IS AB
2231. HIS PAWNBROKERS EDUCATION
BILL. IT HAS SEVEN VOTES.
SITTING RIGHT NOW IS I THAT
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR VOTING AYE WHEN DODD LASER
EYE LASER EYE. NEELO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
WILK I. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ONE ON CALL. HAS TEN VOTES
AGAIN. FILE ITEM TWO BY GIBSON
WAS PULLED. THAT'S AB 2862
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. SO WE
WILL. AND FILE ITEM THREE WAS
ALSO PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S FLORA. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FOUR. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOUR BY FLORA A B
2578. THIS IS HIS NURSING BILL.
IT HAS NINE I VOTES AND NO NO'S.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, LASER
EYE, LASER EYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. EYE.
WILK I WILK I IS THAT ITEM FOUR.
YES SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. EYE TO
NO. OKAY. THAT HAS 11 EYES AND
ONE. NO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
AND GO ON TO ITEM FIVE. ITEM
FIVE BY WENDY CARILLO A B2327.
THIS IS OPTOMETRY. IT HAS NINE
EYE VOTES. THAT MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER A BECKER AYE. GLASER A
LASER AYE. ROTH SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. EYE
ALL RIGHT. THAT GOES TO 12 EYES.
NO NO'S. WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM SIX. MR. VILLA. AB 2453. HE
HAS TEN EYES AND NO NOES. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WITHOUT, CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. ROTH ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FILE ITEM SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI NORRIS.
THIS WAS PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, AB 2559. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
DODD AYE. DODD AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR AYE. ROTH.
THAT'S 12 RIGHT. 12. 12. AYE.
VOTES. NO NO'S. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. FILE ITEM EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AB
2579 HAS TEN AYE VOTES. MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE FLOOR WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. THAT NOW HAS 12
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL
AND MOVE TO ITEM NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AB 2006
22. HE HAS EIGHT AYE VOTES.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. BECKER. BECKER AYE. LASER A
LASER. AYE ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. ITEM NINE. YES. ITEM
NINE ONE. CARILLO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
11 EYES, NO NO'S. AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM TEN BY
GARCIA. THIS IS AB 2757
CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN AYE VOTES.
MOTION IS DUE PASS. SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
DODD AYE. DODD AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE. GLASER.
AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR AYE.
ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS 12 AYE VOTES. NO
NO'S. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FILE ITEM 11. THIS IS GRAYSON.
AB 2774 HAS EIGHT VOTES. AYE.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
DODD AYE. DODD AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE. LASER.
AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. 11 1212.
OKAY. 12 VOTES FOR THAT ONE.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 12 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN AB 3167. HE
HAS 568 AYE VOTES. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. GLASER AYE. BLAZER.
AYE. MENGIBAR. ROTH SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
ALL RIGHT. 11 AYE. VOTES. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 13. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ONE ON. CALL THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF MR. BERMAN'S
BILLS. THE NEXT EIGHT BILLS WILL
ALL BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BERMAN'S
BILLS THAT HE PRESENTED AB 2164,
WHICH IS DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD. AYE
DODD. AYE. ROTH ALL RIGHT. THAT
ONE HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL AGAIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AB 2688. MOTIONS DO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. DODD. DODD AYE.
ROTH ALL RIGHT. THAT'S 12 AYE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
MOVE TO MR. BERMAN'S NEXT BILL.
AB 3054 MOTIONS DO PASS AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. DODD. DODD.
AYE ROTH. AGAIN, 12 VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. MOVE TO MR.
BERMAN'S NEXT BILL. AB 3251.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD DODD.
AYE. ROTH. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S 12
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
MOVE TO MR. BERMAN'S NEXT BILL.
AB 3252, MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE.
NGUYEN BECKER. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
DODD. DODD. AYE ROTH. ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS 11 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. MOVE TO MR. BERMAN'S
NEXT BILL. AB 3253. DO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD.
DODD AYE. ROTH. ALL RIGHT. THAT
HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON.
CALL AND MOVE TO MR. BERMAN'S
NEXT BILL. AB 3254. THAT MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD DODD.
AYE. ROTH. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
12 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
AND MOVE TO MR. BERMAN'S LAST
BILL. AB 3255. MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
DODD DODD. AYE. ROTH ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS 12 VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL. ALL OF YOU HERE,
THEN, ARE ALL CAUGHT UP, AND WE
WILL WAIT A FEW MORE MOMENTS.
BUT ONLY ONE, RIGHT? YEAH. WE'RE
GONNA. NO, WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
UP FILE ITEM ONE AB 2231 BY
GIBSON. THIS IS THE PAWNBROKER'S
EDUCATION BILL. ONE MORE TIME.
IT HAS TEN AYE VOTES. THAT
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD DODD. AYE ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S 11 VOTES. WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE IT ON. CALL.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO RUN THROUGH
THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME. HERE,
FILE ITEM ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON, AB 2231 ON PAWNBROKERS.
IT CURRENTLY HAS 11 AYE VOTES.
AYE THAT ITEM IS OUT. WE HAVE
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION IN THAT
ITEM. FILE ITEM TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. FILE ITEM THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA WAS ALSO
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. SO WE WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA AB 2578 ON
NURSING. THIS ITEM HAS NINE. OH
NO, I'M SORRY. 1011 AYE VOTES
AND ONE NO I BELIEVE YES. ROTH.
HI. ROTH AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
ITEM HAS 12 AYE VOTES. ONE NO
AND IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AB 2327. THIS ITEM HAS
12 AYE VOTES AND NO NOS. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE THAT'S 13 AYE VOTES.
THAT ITEM IS OUT. FILE ITEM SIX
BY VÆ AB 2453 HAS 12. AYE VOTES.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE THAT'S 13 AYE
VOTES THAT ITEMS OUT. FILE ITEM
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AS PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AB 2559
HAS 12 AYE VOTES. ROTH. ROTH
AYE. IT'S 13 VOTES. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AB 2579 HAS
12. AYE VOTES. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
13 VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT. FILE
ITEM NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUAN CARILLO AB 2622 HAS 11 AYE
VOTES. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SMALL
CHÁVEZ. OKAY, THAT'S 12 AYE
VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT. FILE
ITEM TEN AB 2757 BY GARCIA HAS
11 AYE VOTES. IT'S 12 TO 0 AT
ROTH. I'M SORRY. 12 ROTH. AYE.
13. 13. AYE VOTES. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. I'M SORRY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GREYSON'S FILE ITEM 11 AB 2774.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. THAT'S 13 AYE
VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIN FILE ITEM
12 AB 3167 HAS 11. AYE VOTES.
MENGIBAR. ROTH. ROTH AYE. THAT'S
12 AYE VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT.
FILE ITEM 13. THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF MR. BERMAN'S BILLS
2164. HAS 12 VOTES. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE 13 AYE VOTES. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. FILE ITEM 14, AB 2688 BY
BERMAN HAS 12 VOTES. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE 13 AYE. VOTES THAT ITEMS
OUT. FILE ITEM 15 AB 3054 BY
BERMAN HAS 12 AYE VOTES. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE 13 AYE VOTES. THAT
ITEM IS OUT. FILE ITEM 16 AB
3251 BY BERMAN HAS 12 AYE VOTES.
ROTH ROTH. AYE 13. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. FILE ITEM 17 AB 3252. BY
BERMAN HAS 12. AYE VOTES. OH SAY
I'M SORRY. YES. 11. AYE VOTES.
WHEN ROTH ROTH. AYE. THAT'S 12
AYE VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT.
FILE ITEM 18 AB 3253 BY BERMAN.
THIS ITEM HAS 12 AYE VOTES.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. THAT'S 13. THAT
ITEM IS OUT. ITEM 19 AB 3254 BY
BERMAN HAS 12. AYE VOTES. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE 13 AYE VOTES. THAT
ITEM IS OUT. AND THE LAST ITEM
BY ITEM 20 AB 3255 BY BERMAN HAS
12 AYE VOTES. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
13. AYE VOTES. THAT ITEM IS OUT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
FOR THE BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SENATE
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR TODAY.